WE'RE NOW OUT OF OUT OF RECESS
WAITING -- FOR AUTHORS. TO SHOW
UP SO THAT WE COULD -- STAR
HEARING BILLS.
AB MEMBERS TO SHOW UP SO WE
COULD START.
VOTING ON SOME BILLS.
YES WE DID THE CONSENT CALENDAR
[inaudible]
ALL [inaudible]
YEAH
[inaudible]
THERE'S
YES MISTER GIBSON YOU
MAKE.
COMPORT WILL.
AB THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE GIPSON
JUVENILE CHEMICAL SPRAYS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN FIRST OF ALL WANT TO
JUST COMMEND YOU ON YOUR
PREVIOUS MORNING MEDIA THOUGHT
YOU HANDLED -- THAT TOOK ITEM
VERY WELL SO I JUST WANT TO LET
THAT GO ON RECORD.
AGAIN WAS A RECOMMENDS ALIVE
THANK YOU.
WANT TO THANK THE THE COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN AND ALSO THE MEMBERS.
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL -- THIRTEEN TWENTY
ONE A STUDY BILL NUMBER REPEAT A
STUDY BILL WHICH SEEKS TO
IMPROVE OUR UNDERSTANDING OF THE
USE OF CHEMICAL SPRAY IN
JUVENILE DETENTION FACILITIES.
EXCESSIVE USE OF CHEMICAL AGENT
WARNED YOU IN JUVENILE DETENTION
FACILITIES NOT.
ONLY PRODUCE PHYSICAL.
EMOTIONAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
AFFECTS WHAT ALSO INTERFERES
WITH THE REHABILITATION BY
ENDANGERING THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THE U. AND THE STAFF.
MY GOAL IS TO GATHER DATA.
LET ME REPEAT MY GOAL IS TO
GATHER DATA SO THAT THE LA --
CAN GIVE RECOMMENDATIONS ON
ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE CURRENTLY
DETENTION FACILITIES ARE
REQUIRED TO DOCUMENT.
EACH TIME A CORRECTIONAL OFFICER
USE FORCE INCLUDING THE USE OF
CHEMICAL AGENT THIS BILL SEEKS
TO TAKE -- THIS EXISTING DATA
AND REQUIRE IT TO BE REPORTED TO
THE BOARD OF STATE COULDN'T --
CORRECTIONS WITH ME TO PROVIDE
SUPPORTING TESTIMONY IS A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE U.
LAWCENTER WHO WAS SELF INTRODUCE.
HI.
MY NAME IS LUCY SALCEDO CARTER
BUT ACTUALLY I'M GONNA HAVE MY
COLLEAGUE HERE FROM MEAL.
OF GO FIRST.
GOOD AFTERNOON WHEN ASKED OF THE
TO THE COMMITTEE NOW PRESENT
HERE TODAY.
MY NAME IS EVERYBODY WHAT A
NUMBER YOUTH LEADER PROGRAM
ASSISTANT AT ME BY.
IN SALINAS AS WELL AS A COLLEGE
STUDENT MAJORING IN BILINGUAL
BICULTURAL STUDIES.
AS A FORMAL INCARCERATED YOUTH
WHO NOW WORKS CLOSELY WITH YOUNG
PEOPLE I'VE GAINED A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE NEGATIVE
IMPACTS.
THAT CHEMICAL AGENTS.
HAS ON YOU SOCIAL EMOTIONAL WELL
BEING AND I AM HERE TODAY TO
SHARE ON THE IMPORTANCE OF AB.
THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE MANY TIMES I
WAS INCARCERATED AS A YOUTH I
FOUND MYSELF AT THE RECEIVING
END OF A BEING CHEMICALLY
SPRAYED.
BEING SUPPOSED TO CHEMICALS BUT
WAS NOT RARE IT WAS A NORMALIZED
EVERYDAY TYPE EXPERIENCE.
EXPERIENCE BEING PEPPER SPRAYED.
FOR DOING THINGS LIKE NOT LINING
UP PROPERLY TO GET FOOD OR NOT
SITTING IN MY ASSIGNED SEAT.
CHEMICAL SPRING NOT ONLY BRINGS
JUST FOR A DAY BEFORE WE GET
TIMES CAUSING BOIL SKIN PEELING
AND THE WORST PART MAKING EATING
A DIFFICULT TASK.
THE REALITY WAS IN THOSE MOMENTS
WHEN I WAS SPRAYED I FELT
ATTACKED HUMILIATED AND ALONE
WITH NO ONE TO ASK FOR HELP.
FIRE DOES NOT PUT OUT FIRE BUT
RATHER BUILDS ON THE IN MY
EXPERIENCE THE USE OF CHEMICAL
AGENTS ON YOUTH ONLY SERVE AS
ANOTHER BARRIER. TO REALLY
ESTABLISH THOSE RELATIONSHIPS
BETWEEN YOUTH AND STAFF THAT CAN
LEAD TO THE PATH OF
REHABILITATION.
I WOULD STRONGLY ENCOURAGE THIS
COMMITTEE TO COMMIT TO THE IDEA
OF THIS BILL THAT WOULD GATHER
THE DATA AND AND AND AND AND NOW
THIS IS NEEDED IN ORDER TO FIND
ALTERNATIVES SUCH AS CULTURALLY
RELEVANT AND TRAUMA HEALING
INFORMED PROGRAMS.
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE PRACTICES TO
MENTION A FEW.
THAT WOULD AID IN THE OVERALL
WELL BEING OF CALIFORNIAN CAR
SHOULD BE YOU'VE.
I STRONGLY REFUSED TO BELIEVE
THAT THE LIMIT OF OUR CREATIVITY
AND IMAGINATION AND CHEMICAL
AGENTS HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND
BELIEVE CALIFORNIA CAN GET THIS
RIGHT AB THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE
WILL HELP US UNDERSTAND.
WHAT IS HAPPENING TO YOUNG
PEOPLE IN OUR FACILITIES AND
HELP US DEVELOP A PATH FORWARD
TOGETHER [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS LUCY SELFIE THE
CARTER ON THE POLICY ADVOCATE AT
THE YOUTH LAWCENTER.
SO WE HEARD FROM MYSTERY BATA.
ABOUT HIS FIRST HAND EXPERIENCES
WITH BEING SPRAYED IN JUVENILE
FACILITIES AND WATCHING OTHER
YOUTH GET SPRAYED.
WE ALSO HAVE PLENTY OF RESEARCH
SHOWING THE PHYSICAL AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL HARMS TO YOUNG
PEOPLE FROM BEING SPREAD.
WE KNOW THAT CERTAIN FACTORS
EXACERBATE THOSE HARMS INCLUDING
PRE EXISTING RESPIRATORY OR GEE
I CONDITIONS LIKE ASTHMA.
OR EXPOSURE TO TRAUMA AND THESE
ARE FACTORS THAT ARE PRESENT IN
MANY YOUTH IN CUSTODY.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT AS SOON AS THE
FEDERAL MONITORING OF CONDITIONS
IN LA COUNTY JUVENILE PROBATION
FACILITY STOPPED.
THE USE OF CHEMICAL SPRAY IN
THOSE FACILITIES SKYROCKETED.
INCREASING 210023100% IN SOME
FACILITIES.
WE ALSO NOTE THAT.
A FEW JURISDICTIONS IN
CALIFORNIA DO NOT USE SPRAY AND
MOST JURISDICTIONS NATIONWIDE DO
NOT USE SPRAY.
IN THE JUVENILE FACILITIES.
AND LA COUNTY IS CURRENTLY
DEVELOPING A PLAN TO STOP THE
USE OF SPRAY IN THEIR FACILITIES
BY THE END OF THE CALENDAR YEAR.
WHAT WE DON'T KNOW?
IS HOW OFTEN THIS HARMFUL
PRACTICES BEING USED ON YOUTH IN
JUVENILE FACILITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
UNDER CURRENT REGULATIONS AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON STATED
PROBATION HAS TO COLLECT THESE
DATA.
BUT THEY ARE NOT SHARED PUBLICLY.
WE ONLY KNOW ABOUT LA COUNTY'S
USE OF CAM SPRAY BECAUSE THE
PRESS GOT A HOLD OF SOME DATA
AND BECAUSE THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS DECIDED TO REVIEW.
USE.
WE KNOW THAT THIS ISSUE IS
CONTROVERSIAL.
AND THAT THERE IS RESISTANCE TO
GIVING UP OLD FAMILIAR PRACTICES
BUT WE WANT JUVENILE JUSTICE
POLICIES IN CALIFORNIA THAT WE
CAN BE PROUD OF AND THE SHAPE
THESE POLICIES WE NEED DATA AND
WE NEED RESEARCH.
IT'S EVEN MORE IMPORTANT WHEN
THE ISSUE IS SO CONTROVERSIAL.
TO SHAPE GOOD POLICIES WE ALSO
NEED TO KNOW WHAT IS WORKING
WELL IN OTHER LOCALES LOCALES OF
STOP USING THESE PRACTICES AND
ARE STILL KEEPING YOUTH AND
STAFF SAFE.
AB THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE WILL
ALLOW POLICY MAKERS TO KNOW WHAT
IS HAPPENING STATEWIDE WITH
REGARD TO USE OF CAM SPRAY AND
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF WHAT OTHER
LOCALES HAVE FIGURED OUT.
THAT WORK BETTER TO SUPPORT THE
PUBLIC SAFETY AND REHABILITATION
GOALS OF THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM AND FOR THOSE REASONS I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
EXCUSE ME ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES [inaudible]
IN SUPPORT.
PARK -- GEORGE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MIKE'S TO MICHAEL.
DO I NEED.
IS IT ON NOW.
WE WE WE WE IT'S HOT HERE.
GOOD AFTERNOON DOMINIQUE NON FOR
THE CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA PROUD CO SPONSOR
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
LOS SUPER RALPH IN THE PACIFIC
JUVENILE DEFENDER CENTER YOU
NEED GOOD DATA AND GOOD RESEARCH
TO GOOD DO GOOD POLICY WORK WE
SUPPORT THE BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ISRAEL WE ARE WITH ME PART IN
SALINAS SPROUT CO SPONSORS IN
VERY PROUD STRONG SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
GOVERNMENTAL.
JAMES MARTINEZ WITH ME BUT WE
WILL HARDLY SUPPORT THE PROOF IS
IN THE PUDDING [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WHO -- CONTENT DANGEROUS
[inaudible]
THE DOOR.
HELLO MY NAME IS ELISA RUMORS
WITH -- MILPA AND I'M HERE FULLY
SUPPORTER -- AB -- THIRTEEN
TWENTY ONE THANK [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OUR MODEL BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT
WITH ME BUS TRANSPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CHRISTIAN FRANCO PART
OF THE M. B. K. ALLIANCE HERE
SACRAMENTO IN IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK.
MANAGER RUBEN PUBLIC SCHOOL
TEACHERS SAN MATEO COUNTY IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
BUT NO DRUG USE EVER CISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE SUPPORT.
THE JOKER WILSON SERVICES
PROPOSED FOR HIS OFFICE STRONG
SUPPORT.
VICTOR BAILING WITH REACHING
BACK TO OUR YOUTH I KNOW I
WOULDN'T WANNA GET SPRAYED SOME
IN SUPPORT.
ANY SPUR DEPUTY PUBLIC DEFENDER
SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
APRIL MANDATE DEPUTY PUBLIC
DEFENDER SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DANIEL BECAUSE HE ALSO CUMPLE --
SENATOR COUNTY JUVENILE JUSTICE
DELINQUENCY PREVENTION
COMMISSION FOR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESS IN
SUPPORT ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MAKE A MOTION
OF THE BILL [inaudible]
SECOND [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YES MISTER LACKEY YEAH I JUST
HAD A REALLY QUICK COMMENT I
THINK THIS IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE
TO DISCUSS.
THE MATTER BACK TO HAVE A BILL
ABOUT THIS VERY ISSUE SO I WILL
NOT BE VOTING ON THIS ONE TODAY
MAYBE YOU'RE NOT GET TOGETHER.
LOOK FORWARD TO IT THANK YOU.
RIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WHAT
ALSO THANK -- MY WITNESS EDGAR
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY AND LETTING
PEOPLE KNOW WHAT YOU WENT
THROUGH -- THIS IS A VERY VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE AGAIN IT'S A
STUDY BILL AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK BUT I VOTE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU AND I CHAIR FOR
COMMITTEE I ALSO KNOW THAT
YOU'RE WORKING WITH --
INDIVIDUALS ACTUALLY WORKING
THESE FACILITIES ACTUALLY USE A
VERY STRANGE TO DETAIN -- PEOPLE
THAT ARE INCARCERATED SO I'M I'M
GLAD.
YOU WORKED OUT THE PARAMETERS
ARE YOU WORKING NOW SURRENDERS
OF WHAT TO STUDY WILL BE TO
SUGGEST.
THANK YOU THANK YOU RECOMMEND
AND I AND AB THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
JONES SAWYER HIGH JONES -- I
LACKEY.
LACKEY NOT VOTING BARRICADE HAND.
BAUER-KAHAN I DEEP [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
WORK [inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
WICKS.
WICKS I MEASURES ON CALL WE TWO
MORE MEMBERS TO GET HERE THANK
YOU.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FIVE A. B..
ONE FIVE ZERO ONE LOW
[inaudible]
FORENSIC BALLISTIC AND FIREARMS
PROCEDURES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS -- HE SAID IT --
ALREADY WITH RESPECT TO THE
DEFINITION HERE -- BUT WANT TO
GIVE YOU EXAMPLE OF THE UTILITY
OF THIS TECHNOLOGY FOR EXAMPLE
IN ALAMEDA COUNTY A CRIME WAS
ABLE TO LINK COVER COVERED GUN
TO BALLISTICS EVIDENCE AND THREE
SHOOTINGS IN SAN FRANCISCO.
AND CONTRA COSTA COUNTY FOR
EXAMPLE INVESTIGATORS USED NOW
I'VE BEEN TO CONNECT THIS CARTED
GUN. TWO THREE OTHER RECENT
SHOOTINGS THAT PLAGUE TOOK PLACE
FROM FREMONT TO OUR LINDA WITH
ME AT OTHER ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
REPRESENTING.
A DISTRICT ATTORNEY JEFF ROSEN
FROM SANTA CLARA COUNTY.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS MICHAEL
VIDMAR WHO DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY SANTA CLARA COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE.
AND THE GUN CRIMES PROSECUTOR
FOR OUR OFFICE WHICH FALLS IN
FOR CRIME STRATEGIES UNIT TEAM.
GUN VIOLENCE PLACE COMMUNITIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA LEAVING A
DEVASTATING A COSTLY TRAIL
WORTHY OF ALL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND PUBLIC RESOURCES.
HOWEVER THERE IS AN EVIDENCE
BASED SOLUTION AVAILABLE.
IT IS PROVEN TO SOLVE GUN CRIMES
AND WE URGE THIS BODY TO SUPPORT
AB FIFTEEN NO ONE TO HELP
IDENTIFY YOUR MOST VIOLENT
CRIMINALS AND BRING THEM TO
JUSTICE.
BY TAKING CRIME GUNS AND SHELL
CASINGS FROM EVERY CRIME SCENE
WHERE AGAIN WAS USED.
ANALYZING THEM AND ENTERING THEM
IT'S THE NATIONAL DATABASE WE
CAN LEARN LINK UNSOLVED GUN
CRIMES.
AND USE THE INFORMATION LEARNED
TO BUILD A CASE THAT SOLVES
MULTIPLE CRIMES.
WE KNOW THIS TESTING WORKS HE
DRAMATIC EXAMPLES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY UNEXPECTED LINKS BETWEEN
SHOOTINGS HAVE WHAT'S THE
APPREHENSION SHOOTING OF
PROSECUTION OF SHOOTERS.
BUT IT REQUIRES EVERYONE TO TEST
THEIR GUNS IN CASINGS ALL OF THE
TIME.
SENSIBLE IMPLEMENTING THE GUN
RELATED INTELLIGENCE PROGRAM IN
THE FALL OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY
CRIME LAB HAS IDENTIFIED
HUNDREDS OF LINKED SHOOTINGS
INCLUDING MURDERS.
ATTEMPTED MURDERS CARJACKINGS
ARM ROBBERIES AND DRIVE BY
SHOOTINGS.
WITHOUT THIS LAW WE KNOW THAT
MURDER WEAPONS ARE GONNA BE
REMAINING ON SHELVES AND TESTED.
WE KNOW THE CRITICAL LEAVES IN
SHOOTING SPREES ARE GONNA REMAIN
IMPROPER TO ROOMS.
NOT BEING UTILIZED.
THIS BILL WILL CLOSE THIS USING
COSTLY GAP AND THIS IS NOT A NEW
TECHNOLOGY.
THIS BILL MANDATES THAT WE
HARNESS THE POWER OF TOOLS WE
ALREADY HAVE TO COMMUTE KEEP OUR
COMMUNITY SAFE.
WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE IS
CONCERNS ABOUT COSTS AND WE
SHARE THE CONCERN ANTICIPATE
FUTURE DEBATE ABOUT FUNDINGS.
HOWEVER WE BELIEVE THIS THE
VITAL TECHNOLOGY WORTHY OF
EFFORT IN FUNDING AND GIVEN THE
EXPENSE OF A SINGLE HOMICIDE
INVESTIGATION THE COST THIS
PROGRAM SEEMS UNDENIABLY WORTH
THE EFFORT INVESTMENT TO PROVIDE
INVALUABLE LEADS.
IN OUR MOST SERIOUS CASES.
WE STRONGLY ENCOURAGE THE STATE
TO SHOW COMMITMENT AND
LEADERSHIP IN THIS REGARD
SUPPORTING PROVING GUN
TECHNOLOGY THROUGH THIS BILL ON
BEHALF OF GUN CRIME VICTIMS
AROUND THE STATE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
YES.
AMANDA WILCOX ON BEHALF OF BRADY
CALIFORNIA.
SO MANY CRIME GUNS GO UNSOLVED.
AND SADLY AS MANY OF OUR ODD
BRADY CHAPTER MEMBERS AROUND THE
STATE NO AN UNSOLVED CRIME IS
VERY HARD AND VICTIMS WHO ARE
SEEKING ANSWERS AND
ACCOUNTABILITY -- JUST AS
IMPORTANT AS THE FACT THAT ARM
CRIMINALS WHO ARE NOT IDENTIFIED
AND APPREHENDED -- ARE IN THE
POSITION WHERE THEY CAN INFLICT
MORE HARM.
THEREFORE IS IMPORTANT OBVIOUSLY
TO SOLVE CRIMES AND TO THE
EXTENT THAT THE SHARING OF
BALLISTIC INFORMATION HELPS TO
SOLVE CRIMES IT'S GOOD POLICY --
THE BRADY CAMPAIGN STRONGLY
SUPPORTS THE RECOMMENDATION MADE
BY THE INTERNSHIP INTERNATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF CHIEFS OF POLICE.
AND THAT RECOMMENDATION IS THE
TIMELY PROCESSING OF CRIME GUN
TEST FIRES A BALLISTIC EVIDENCE
THROUGH.
NINE THE RESOLUTION RESOLUTION
FINDS A BALLISTIC EVIDENCE FROM
A CRIME GUM CAN BE USED TO LINK
A FIREARM TO PRIOR PRIOR CRIMES
AND TO LINK TO OR MARK CRIMES
TOGETHER AND CAN PROVIDE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WITH TIMELY.
AND ACTIONABLE INFORMATION TO
HELP IT AND DENTAL FIVE AND
APPREHEND ARM SUSPECTS BEFORE
THEY DO MORE HARM AND YOU JUST
HEARD ABOUT HOW THAT IS USED --
AS A MATTER POLICY I DON'T THINK
THIS IS CONTROVERSIAL AT ALL HI
THE HANG UP OF COURSE IS THE
COST -- EXISTING LAW PERMITS
LOCAL JR LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES TO SUBMIT THE LANGUAGE
ARTS SUBMIT THAT BALLISTICS
EVIDENCE THIS BILL REQUIRE THEM
TO DO THAT AGAIN AS A MATTER OF
POLICY.
THIS MAKES SENSE TO GOOD POLICY
AND MY RECOMMENDATION WOULD BE
TO HAVE THE FUNDING DEBATE IN
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WHERE
BELONGS WAS A PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE.
I READ YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
THANK YOU THANK YOU ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
CALVIN QUICK WITH BAY AREA
STUDENT ACTIVISTS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ARE A WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
A HALF OFF ON GIVE US A FEW
SECONDS.
WELCOME. TO ENTER THE EXPRESS
THIS.
A LOT OF AND WITH THE SYSTEM
PROCESSES MANY THINGS MOVING
.
ARE YOU IN SUPPORT.
OF MR BONTA I MISSED A LOW'S
BILL. FIFTEEN OH ONE SAY YOUR
NAME.
ORGANIZATION AND THAT YOUR
SUPPORT MARISSA MAZA -- FROM
RICHMOND CALIFORNIA I'M IN
OPPOSITION.
ALL OF IT.
OKAY THEM WAIT.
COME ON MR.
CHORUS ALSO.
IF YOU MISTER JOHN MEMBERS
COURCELLES ALONG WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION REGRETTABLY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
WE'RE NOT OPPOSED TO TESTING
FIREARMS OR TESTING CARTRIDGES
THAT HAVE BEEN FOUND AT A CRIME
SCENE OR THAT ARE -- THE RESULT
OF UNLAWFUL USE -- THE CONCERN
HERE I THINK IS IS TWO FOLD ONE
IS ALREADY BEEN DISCUSSED THE
THE THE COSTLY UNFUNDED MANDATE
THAT THIS BILL PROPOSES.
AS MISS WILCOX SAYS THAT.
THE CURRENT LAW PERMITS THE SORT
OF THING TO HAPPEN IT HAPPENS AS
A MATTER OF PRACTICE NOW AS
RESOURCES AND TIME IN
INVESTIGATIONS PERMIT -- BUT
BECAUSE THE BILL CONTAINS NO
FUNDING IT'S IT'S A IT'S A HARD
CONVERSATION HAVE.
A FURTHER WERE WERE CONCERNED
THAT THIS PRIORITIZE THE TESTING
OF CERTAIN TYPES OF EVIDENCE.
FROM CERTAIN CRIME SCENES OR
CERTAIN SITUATIONS AT THE
EXPENSE OF OTHERS SO.
THERE'S NO SORT OF
PRIORITIZATION THERE'S NO SORT
OF MENTION OF WILL WINDOWS THIS
GUN GET TESTER WHEN THIS CAR
JUST GET TESTED.
THIS WOULD BE A LEGISLATIVE
MANDATE THAT THIS TYPE OF
PARTICULAR EVIDENCE BE PROCESSED.
AND PRESUMABLY IT GOES TO THE
FRONT OF THE LINE AHEAD OF
ANYTHING ELSE BECAUSE THERE'S NO
LANGUAGE THAT THAT INDICATES ONE
WAY OR THE OTHER -- MANY TYPES
OF EVIDENCE AND INFORMATION
ROUTINELY GATHER DURING THE
COURSE OF INVESTIGATION.
TRAIN INVESTIGATOR SHOULD HAVE
THE DISCRETION TO PROCESS THAT
EVIDENCE -- IN THE CONTEXT OF
THE INDIVIDUAL SITUATION WITH
THE BENEFIT OF THEIR EXPERIENCE
AND EXPERTISE AND TRAINING --
AND INSTEAD OF MANDATING IT HERE
FOR TO SAY EVERY GUN MUST BE
TESTED EVERY KARGES MUST BE
TESTED -- WE THINK IT'S BEST
LEFT TO THOSE -- WITH THE
EXPERIENCE ON THE GROUND AND SO
RESPECTFULLY FOR THOSE REASONS
WITH US YOU KNOW.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER IN
OPPOSITION OF FIFTEEN OH ONE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I MAKE A MOTION TO MOVE THE BELL.
THEN YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH RESPECT BASS RIVAL.
A CHURCH RECOMMENDED AND I AND
HOPEFULLY.
YOU CAN WORK OUT AS YOU GO TO I
GUESS TO APPROACH.
OF THE FUNDING AND RESOURCE
ISSUE.
THE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION HAS
BROUGHT UP.
ON A. B. FIFTEEN OH ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER.
CHEN SIR HI LACKEY LACKEY I
BAUER-KAHAN.
BAUER-KAHAN I DEEP.
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
QUIRK [inaudible]
SANTIAGO WICKS.
MEASURES ON CALL YOU NEED
[inaudible]
TO THANK YOU -- SO.
SHOWS MR STONE [inaudible]
MRS STONE.
SIGNED IN BEFORE YOU
[inaudible] THIRTEEN NINETY
WHAT EVERY ITEM SEVENTEEN
WHATEVER YOU WANT TO BEGIN THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS.
AB THIRTEEN NINETY MAKES A MINOR
EXPANSION TO THE TRANSITIONAL
AGE YOUTH PILOT PROGRAM THIS IS
A PROGRAM THAT EXISTS.
IN ALAMEDA DO YOU NAPA NEVADA
SANTA CLARA AND FUTURE A
COUNTIES IT'S A VOLUNTARY
PROGRAM.
THAT IS BASED AROUND.
A YOUTH OR SOMEBODY IN THIS AGE
GROUP ENTERING A DEFERRED
JUDGMENT AND ALLOWING THEM TO GO.
TO JUVENILE HALL INSTEAD OF TO
THE PRISONS WE'VE DONE A LOT OF
WORK.
AROUND ALIGNING THINGS TO
APPROPRIATE AGE GROUPS AND THE
CURRENTLY UNDER THE PROGRAM THE
AGE.
IS BETWEEN EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY
ONE ALL THIS BILL DOES IS MOVE
THAT TO UNDER TWENTY FIVE
CONSISTENT WITH BRAIN SCIENCE IN
THIS IS A REQUEST.
THAT COMES OUT OF SANTA CLARA
COUNTY WHERE THE CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICER IS INTERESTED IN
EXPANDING THE PROGRAM.
THIS IS PUT IN PLACE IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN IT'S BEEN A
VERY EFFECTIVE PROGRAM.
áP PROVIDING ALL ALTERNATIVES.
AND ASSISTING YOU TO ADDRESS
THEIR ISSUES IN YOUR BACK INTO
SOCIETY APPROPRIATELY SO WE'RE
JUST TRYING TO DO THIS MINOR
CHANGE TO THE PROGRAM TO
INCORPORATE MORE INDIVIDUALS AND
WITH THAT I ASK FOR IT EITHER.
THANK YOU YES GOOD AFTERNOON MR
TURN MEMBERS DANIEL SANCHEZ WITH
THE CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIA HERE UP PLEASE BE A
SPONSOR AND I THINK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER STONE FOR THIS --
AS AS MENTIONED THIS IS A A
MODEST CHANGE BUT A VERY
IMPORTANT ONE TO MOVE IT.
THE AGE OF ELIGIBILITY UP TO
TWENTY FIVE AGAIN UPON LOCAL IN
D. T. AGREEMENT THAT THE FOCUS
REALLY IS ON MAKING SURE THAT IT
IS DONE IN A LOCAL CITING THAT
MAKES SENSE FOR ALL OF THE
VARIOUS PARTNERS AND
PRACTITIONERS -- THIS WOULD
ALIGN WITH BRAIN DEVELOPMENT
RESEARCH -- RELATIVE TO TO YOUNG
ADULTS AND AND THE FOCUS REALLY
IS ON WANTING.
TO WORK WITH THESE YOUNG ADULTS
IN A MANNER IN WHICH WE CAN BE
MOST EFFECTIVE IN GETTING THEM
SERVICES THAT THEY NEED GET
THEIR RECORDS CLEARED AND AND
GET KIND OF ON THE THE RIGHT
PATH -- GOING FORWARD SO FOR
THOSE REASONS WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER.
PEOPLE IN SUPPORT -- ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION.
HE WAS JUST WALKING THROUGH OR
IS IT OKAY -- ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- WITH THAT
YOU MAY CLOSE MISTER STONE ASK
YOUR AYE VOTES CHAIR
[inaudible]
IS.
I OF THERE'S A MOTION FROM THE
CHAIR [inaudible]
A SECOND.
YOU MAY CALL THE ROLL.
ON A. B. THIRTEEN NINETY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS JONES SAWYER
AGENTS ARE AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY NOPE BAUER-KAHAN DEEP.
KAMLAGER-DOVE HI KAMLAGER-DOVE I
QUIRK [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
WICKS.
AT MEASURES ARE CALL NEED A FEW
MEMBERS TO GET BACK YES.
WELL TO MISTER BONTA THERE WAS
QUICK
[inaudible]
EVERY DAY.
BURKE WE ARE APPROVED
.
YES MISS WICKS.
AB SIXTEEN OH THREE ITEM NUMBER.
TWENTY NINE CALIFORNIA VIOLENCE
INTERVENTION AND PREVENTION
GRANT PROGRAM.
HI NO THIS IS A IS A TRANSFER TO
JUVENILES YEAH NOBODY.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND THEN WILL BE
THE ONE ALL YOU DO AYE AB
EIGHTEEN FIRST OKAY.
SORRY THAT'S WHY I HAVE A TEAM.
LEVINE OKAY FIREARMS EXCISE TAX
I AM THE BATTLING MY INNER MARC
LEVINE OKAY.
YEAH THE MARC LEVINE BILL OKAY.
AT THANK YOU -- CHAIRMAN AND
FELLOW COLLEAGUES ON THIS
COMMITTEE AB EIGHTEEN WOULD
IMPOSE AN EXCISE TAX ON A
RETAILER IN THE AMOUNT OF TWENTY
FIVE DOLLARS PER FIREARM.
ON THE SALE IN THE STATE OF THE
ON THE SALE OF THE STATE OF HAND
GUNS OR SEMI AUTOMATIC RIFLES OR
SHOTGUNS THE REVENUE GENERATED
BY THIS TAX WOULD PROVIDE A
STEADY FUNDING STREAM. FOR THE
CALVET PROGRAM WHICH IS THE
CALIFORNIA VIOLENCE INTERVENTION
PROGRAM WHICH THIS BILL ALSO
ESTABLISHES IN STATUTE WE KNOW
THAT THESE PROGRAMS WORK WE'VE
SEEN A REDUCTION GUN VIOLENCE
AND MANY OF OUR CITIES.
BECAUSE OF THE CAL THE PROGRAMS.
THE ECONOMIC COST OF GUNS IN
AMERICA IS STAGGERING.
ACCORDING TO JOBS JOHNS HOPKINS
STUDY U. S. EMERGENCY ROOM
VISITS FOR GUNSHOT WOUNDS COST
APPROXIMATELY TWO POINT EIGHT
BILLION PER YEAR.
ANNUAL TOTAL COST ESTIMATES FROM
GUN VIOLENCE REACH TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY TWO BILLION.
IF MEDICAL LAW ENFORCEMENT TRAIL
OTHER COSTS ARE AGGREGATED AND
THIS THE CDC ARE ALSO FOUND THAT
FROM TWENTY FOURTEEN TO TWENTY
SIXTEEN GUN HOMICIDES INCREASED
18% IN THE STATE.
AB EIGHTEEN WOULD ENSURE A
FUNDING FOR CALVET ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS AND BOLSTER RESOURCES TO
ADDRESS SERIOUS VIOLENCE IN
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
WITH ME TODAY IS -- IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL ARE YOU FREE LOOK
FROM DIFFERENCE.
AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
THE TEAM'S CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE -- MY NAME SORRY FOR
LIKE I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
DIFFERENCE LAWCENTER SPRING GUN
VIOLENCE AGAINST IF YOU
ORGANIZATION LED BY FORMER
CONGRESSWOMAN AND GUN VIOLENCE
SURVIVOR GABBY GIFFORDS.
OUR ORGANIZATIONS TOP PRIORITY
IN CALIFORNIA IS TO INCREASE AND
STRENGTHEN THE STATE'S
INVESTMENT IN PROGRAMS THAT WORK.
TO DROP CYCLES OF SHOOTINGS
INJURY TRAUMA AND RETALIATION.
THAT'S BECAUSE THE STATE OF
ACHIEVED THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
REDUCTIONS OF GUN VIOLENCE IN
RECENT YEARS.
HAVE TAKEN MEANINGFUL ACTION ON
GUN SAFETY REFORM AND COMMITTED
SIGNIFICANT ONGOING FUNDING TO
THESE TARGETED PROGRAMS IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
IN CALIFORNIA WITH YOUR
LEADERSHIP MISTER CHAIRMAN
LEGISLATURE ACTED TO REPLICATE
THESE BACKS BEST PRACTICES BY
CREATING AND FUNDING THE
CALIFORNIA VIOLENCE INTERVENTION
AND PREVENTION GRANT PROGRAM
CALLED CALVET FOR SHORT.
THE PROGRAM PROVIDES COMPETITIVE
MATCHING GRANTS FOR CITIES AND
CBO'S IMPLEMENT EVIDENCE BASED
BROWN'S REDUCTION INITIATIVES AS
HELP THE FUNDS IN THE MOST
EFFECTIVE INNOVATIVE APPROACHES
IN THE NATION.
BUT THE FUNDING FOR THIS PROGRAM
IS WOEFULLY INADEQUATE TO MEET
OUR COMMUNITIES NEEDS.
THIS BILL WOULD INCORPORATE
LANGUAGE FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WICKS EIGHTY SIXTEEN OH THREE
THE BREAK THE CYCLE OF VIOLENCE
ACT. TO ENSURE THAT THESE FUNDS
CONTINUE TO BE DIRECTED TO THE
MOST.
EFFECTIVE AND TARGET PROGRAMS
THE COMMUNITIES WITH THE
GREATEST NEED.
IT WOULD ALSO PROVIDE A
REASONABLE AND APPROPRIATELY
TARGETED MEANS OF SUSTAINING
REVENUE FOR THIS PURPOSE IN THE
LONG TERM.
FARM INDUSTRY TAXES ARE
HISTORICALLY LONG STANDING IN
THIS COUNTRY AT THE STATE LEVEL.
AND AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL TO
WHERE THE PITTMAN ROBERTSON ACT
HAS SINCE NINETEEN NINETEEN
IMPOSED A 10211% TAX ON THE SALE
OF GUNS AND AMMUNITION.
BY MANUFACTURERS IMPORTERS AND
PRODUCERS.
BUT NOT FIREARMS SELLERS.
REVENUES FROM THIS FEDERAL TAX
WHICH WAS DESCRIBED BY THE NRA
AS A QUOTE LEGISLATIVE MODEL.
AND A QUOTE FRIEND OF THE HUNTER.
FUND WILDLIFE CONSERVATION
EFFORTS THAT REMEDIATE SOME OF
THE IMPACTS FIREARMS HAVE ON
WILD ANIMAL POPULATIONS THROUGH
HUNTING.
THIS BILL WOULD SIMILARLY PLACE
A REASONABLE TAX ON THE PART OF
OUR MINISTRY EXEMPTED FROM THE
FEDERAL TAX COMMERCIAL RETAIL
FARM DEALERS.
IN ORDER TO HELP REMEDIATE THE
DEVASTATING AFFECT THE FARMS
BECAUSE MANY HUMAN FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
THIS BILL IS NOT INTENDED TO
PENALIZE FARM SELLERS OR
OTHERWISE DISCOURAGE LAWFUL
COMMERCE ARE ACTIVITY WHATSOEVER
BUT WOULD REASONABLY GENERATE
SUSTAINABLE REVENUE FOR
IMPORTANT.
AND PROPERLY TARGETED BECAUSE OF
THESE REASONS I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT IT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
AN ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF EVERY
TOWN FOR GUN SAFETY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ADAM.
AMANDA WILCOX BRADY CALIFORNIA
UNITED AGAINST GUN VIOLENCE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CALVIN QUICK WITH BAY AREA STERN
ACTIVISTS IN STRONG SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GET AFTERNOON DOMINIQUE NOW FOR
THE CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
ANY.
OTHER WITNESS ANY WOODS IS IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
THE RECORD AND WE WITH NATIONAL
RIFLE ASSOCIATION.
I'M ALSO HERE FOR CALIFORNIA
RIFLE AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION
THEY WERE IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO AB -- EIGHTEEN I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT
FEES AND TAXES THAT GUN OWNERS
ALREADY DO YOU PAY.
AS WAS MENTIONED THERE'S 11%
FEDERAL EXCISE TAX.
ON ON THE HELLO.
FIREARMS AND AMMUNITION FOR CON --
CONSERVATION EFFORTS THROUGH THE
PITTMAN ROBERTSON ACT -- THERE'S
A NINETEEN DOLLAR GROSS THE
WHICH WE'RE GONNA BE TALKING
ABOUT -- INCREASING JUST LATER
ON TODAY OTHERSA ONE DOLLAR
FIREARM SAFETY ACT BE THERE'S A
FIVE DOLLAR FIREARM SAFETY IN
ENFORCEMENT THE END BEFORE YOU
CAN.
ACQUIRE ANY FIREARM THE STATE
YOU NEED TO PAY TWENTY FIVE
DOLLARS FOR A FIREARM SAFETY
CERTIFICATE OR AN ALTERNATIVE
WHICH COULD BE -- A CERTIFICATE
OF ELIGIBILITY OR CCW WHICH ARE
EVEN MORE EXPENSIVE THAN THE
TWENTY FIVE DOLLAR FIVE YEAR
FIREARMS SAFETY CERTIFICATE THE
NOT TO MENTION STATE AND LOCAL
TAXES -- WHEN IT COMES -- TO
VIOLENCE PREVENTION THE
COMMITTEE THIS SHOULD BE A
MATTER OF GENERAL CONCERN FOR
EVERYONE AND GUN OWNER SHOULD
NOT BE SINGLED OUT TO PAY YET
ANOTHER TAX.
AND ANOTHER FEE -- TO FOR THE
FOR THESE PROGRAMS WITHOUT WHEN
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBER SAMPRAS
REPRESENTING GUN OWNERS
CALIFORNIAN AUTHORIZED. TO SPEAK
ON BEHALF OF NATIONAL SHOOTING
SPORTS FOUNDATION OUTDOOR SPORTS
ONES COALITION -- AND
CALIFORNIA'S SPORTSMEN'S LOBBY --
MEANT MISTER CHAIRMAN THIS READ
THIS ISSUE MAY BE RESOLVED FOR
US BY THE SUPREME COURT VERY
SOON.
THEY PRESENTLY OPENED UP A
DOCKET. TO ACCEPT THE CASE
JEREMY KEPLER VERSUS THE UNITED
STATES.
IT HAS TO DO WITH TAXATION OF A
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT OF A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT THIS TAX
ABSOLUTELY -- IS A TAX ON THE
EXERCISING OF A CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT NOW THIS CASE WILL NOT
ONLY AFFECT THIS ONE BUT ALL OF
THE OTHER -- TAXES THAT ARE ON
AMMUNITION AND AND AND PARTS
THAT ARE ESSENTIAL TO MAKE GUNS.
GUNS WORK -- THERE HAVE BEEN
MULTIPLE.
CASES THAT HAVE SAID.
YOU CANNOT TAX.
THE EXERCISING OF A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT.
PEOPLE SAY WELL WE TAX CARS
WHILE DRIVING IS NOT A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT.
YOU HAVE THE RIGHT TO TRAVEL BUT
THE MEANS OF TRANSPORTATION ARE
NOT PROTECTED.
BY THE CONSTITUTION -- THERE ARE
MANY THINGS THAT THAT THAT YOU
KNOW.
PEOPLE WILL SAY HEY WE WANT TO
GO AHEAD AND TAXES WELL THE
THAT'S ALL WELL AND GOOD.
BUT THE SECOND AMENDMENT IS A
CONSTANT INDIVIDUAL
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT AND THAT
PROTECTS THE ABILITY FOR PEOPLE
TO ACQUIRE TO USED TO TRANSPORT.
TO TO TO HAVE WITH THEM TO KEEP
AND BEAR ARMS -- THIS IS EQUATED
TO A VOTING TAX THAT'S
UNCONSTITUTIONAL IT'S BEEN HELD
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
AND AND HERE YOU WILL NOT BE
ALLOWED TO EXERCISE A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT UNLESS YOU
PAY A TAX.
THAT IS PLAINLY.
SIMPLY UNCONSTITUTIONAL FOR
THESE REASONS WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
THE GERMAN JEFFREY GOLDBERG FOR
CALIFORNIA WATERFALL SO SEE
ASIAN IN OPPOSITION [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
YES SIR.
SENATE GRANTS YOUR PA IN A
REMEMBER STRONG OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU SIR.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
IT WAS KAMLAGER-DOVE.
HI A GOOD AFTERNOON SO I HAD A
QUESTION -- I HAD A COUPLE
ACTUALLY BUT THE FIRST ONE WAS
WITH REGARDS TO THE CAL -- V. I.
P. PROGRAM IT SAYS IN THE
LANGUAGE THAT.
THE GRAND SO WE MADE ON A
COMPETITIVE BASIS TO CITIES THAT
ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
BY VIOLENCE.
BUT IT DOESN'T NECESSARILY FOR
DOESN'T SPECIFICALLY SAY GUN
VIOLENCE SO CAN YOU TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT BECAUSE A
I WOULD SORT OF WONDER HOW THIS.
SHARE OF FUNDS WOULD BE
DISTRIBUTED IF IT WOULD BE
EQUITABLE.
IF IT IS SHARED BASED ON THE
KINDS OF VIOLENCE OR IS IT KINDS
OF GUN VIOLENCE I MEAN SINCE
IT'S A TAX ON GUNS I WOULD
ASSUME ARE EXPECT THAT THERE'S
SOME SORT OF CORRELATION.
CAN YOU SPEAK TO THAT.
SO THIS PROGRAM IS UP THIS BILL
WOULD AUTHORIZE AN EXISTING
PROGRAM STATUTES THIS EXISTING
CALVET PROGRAM -- IT DOES A
COMMUNITY VIOLENCE AND
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ABOUT
BONDS HAS BEEN MEASURED AS
HOMICIDES IN SHOOTINGS.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF HOMICIDES
ARE FATAL SHOOTINGS -- AND WE'D
BE ABSOLUTELY HAPPY. TO TO
CONTINUE TO FOCUS THE PROGRAM
SPECIFICALLY MORE EVEN MORE
SPECIFIC LINK ON VIOLENCE -- IN
PRACTICE THE PROGRAM THAT IS
FUNDED ARE ABSOLUTELY TARGETED
AT INTERRUPTING CYCLES OF
SHOOTINGS AND RETALIATION -- AND
I'D BE VERY HAPPY. TO TO WORK
WITH ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE AND
COMMITTEE TO TO MAKE THAT EVEN
CLEAR IN THE LANGUAGE THAT IS
THE WAY IT'S WORKING IN PRACTICE
AND THAT'S OUR INTENT OKAY.
AND THEN THE TAXES FOR RETAILERS
THE TAXES.
THE AMENDED LANGUAGE RIGHT THERE
MAY HAVE BEEN SOME
MISCOMMUNICATION BEFORE BUT THE
AMENDED LANGUAGE BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE IS A TAX ON ON RETAIL
FIREARM SELLERS OF SAID THE SALE
OF NEW FIREARMS.
BY FIRING DEALERS OKAY AND MY
ASSUMPTION WOULD BE THEY WOULD
PASS IT DOWN AND THIS IS MY
FINAL QUESTION -- MY CONCERN IS
THAT THE RETAILERS OR ACT
ASSUMPTION IS THAT THE RETAILERS
OF PASSED THE TAX DOWN TO THE
CONSUMER LIKE THEY ALWAYS DO.
DO YOU HAVE ANY CONCERNS ABOUT
THE PROSPECT OF THIS SORT OF
DISCOURAGING FOLKS FROM
PURCHASING IN THE LEGAL MARKET
AND WANTING TO REVERT BACK TO
PURCHASING IN THE ILLEGAL MARKET
WHICH WE TEND TO KIND OF TALK
ABOUT NOT WANTING TO HAVE.
SORT OF TWO RESPONSES THE FIRST
IS -- I ACTUALLY DO.
I THINK SOME LIKELY WOULD PASSED
THE THE CHARGE ON TO THEIR
PURCHASERS BUT MANY WOULDN'T
THIS IS A HIGHLY PROFITABLE
INDUSTRY FOR A GUN SALES HAVE
MORE THAN DOUBLED IN CALIFORNIA
IN THE LAST DECADE -- AND MANY
OF THESE ARE CORPORATIONS THAT
JUST RECEIVED A BIG FEDERAL TAX
CUT -- BUT SECOND I THINK THE
TWENTY FIVE DOLLAR.
FEE OF A NEW FIRE PURCHASES AB.
I THINK YOU MEANT IS NOT LARGE
ENOUGH TO REALLY SHIFT BEHAVIOR
WHEN THE AVERAGE FIREARM COSTS
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS TO FIFTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS FOR NEW FIREARMS -- THIS
ALSO WOULDN'T APPLY TO NON SEMI
AUTOMATIC RIFLES AND SHOTGUNS
ARE MOST COMMONLY USED FOR
HUNTING SO THIS IS NOT A PLAN TO
USE FIREARMS THAT YOU'RE BUYING
FROM ANOTHER UNLICENSED PERSON
THROUGH A DEALER.
SO.
OUR THOUGHT IS THAT WE'RE
OBVIOUSLY NOT INTERESTED IN AND
ENCOURAGING ANYONE TO GO TO THE
LEGAL MARKET -- BUT WE THINK A
TWENTY FIVE DOLLAR FEE FOR THESE
REASONS IS NOT LARGE ENOUGH TO
REALLY SHIFT BEHAVIOR MUCH
SMALLER THAN ON AVERAGE THE
FEDERAL MANUFACTURERS TAX.
WHICH IS A 10211% ON USUALLY
FIVE HUNDRED TO FIFTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS AND BE SIGNIFICANTLY
LARGER THAN THIS WOULD BE.
SURE THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ON BEHALF OF MARK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU AND IT IS THERE A
MOTION OR DO WE DO THAT ARI.
OKAY.
IS I SECOND THEM.
OF BEACH CHAIRS ARE IS
RECOMMENDED I IN A ACTUALLY A MY
FRIEND FROM THE NRA ENOUGH
FIREARMS.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE.
WHAT HAPPENS WITH A COURT CASE
AS FAR AS THE SECOND AMENDMENT
BECAUSE I KNOW?
BY THE FIRST AMENDMENT I KNOW I
PAY TAXES ON MY NEWSPAPERS AND
MAGAZINES AND THINGS OF THAT
NATURE AND SO IF.
AND I PAY A LOT FOR A LOT OF
DIFFERENT PUBLICATIONS SOFA.
IF THEY REVOKED.
ALL OF THAT I'D LIKE TO KNOW
BECAUSE AGAIN I PAY A LOT. FOR A
LOT OF PUBLICATIONS SO.
JUDGE RECOMMENDED AYE.
ON AB EIGHTEEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE REVENUE TAX
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER.
CHEN SIR HI LACKEY LACKEY NO
BARRICADE HAN.
DEEP NO NO KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I QUIRK
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
WICKS HI [inaudible]
WICKS I ON CALL NEEDS TO MORE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
IN [inaudible]
LOS [inaudible]
THE AND YOU HAVE [inaudible]
ANOTHER BILL. NINETEEN ONCE I
CONSENT BUT FOURTEEN TWENTY
THREE FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE
JUVENILE TRANSFERS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I WANT TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
WORK.
AND WILL ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS.
CALIFORNIA LAW ALLOWS SOME USED
TO BE TRIED IN THE ADULT
CRIMINAL SYSTEM DEPENDING ON
THEIR AGE.
AT THE TIME OF THE OFFENSE AND
THE SERIOUSNESS OF THE OFFENSE.
JUVENILES ARE TRANSFERRED TO
ADULT COURT THROUGH A TRANSFER
HEARING PROCESS FOR THE PURPOSES
OF A TRANSFER HEARING THE JUDGE
ASSUMES THE CHARGES TO BE TRUE.
IT IS RELATIVELY COMMON FOR
INVESTIGATION AFTER TRANSFERRING
TO REVEAL THAT THE CRIME THAT
OCCURRED WAS NOT AS SERIOUS OR
REGIONALLY AS ORIGINALLY THOUGHT.
AND OCCASIONALLY THE YOUNG
PERSON DID NOT COMMIT THE
ALLEGATION THEY THEY ALLEGE
OFFENSE AT ALL.
UNDER CURRENT LAW ONCE A
DECISION IS MADE TO TRANSFER
THEY MAY NOT BE REFERRED BACK TO
THE JUVENILE SYSTEM EVEN WHEN
THE FELONY CHARGES THAT MADE
THEM ELIGIBLE FOR TRANSFER ARE.
OUR A AND PLAYED A ROLE IN THEIR
TRANSFER ARTIST MR FOUND TO BE
UNTRUE.
THIS IS PATENTLY UNFAIR
SITUATION.
AB FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE
PROVIDES A NARROWLY TAILORED
REMEDY TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE BY
ESTABLISHING A PROCESS FOR A
JUVENILE TO REQUEST THE CRIMINAL
COURT TO TRANSFER CASE TO
JUVENILE COURT IN A LIMITED
NUMBER OF SITUATIONS IN WHICH
THE BASIS FOR THE ORIGINAL
TRANSFER IS LATER DETERMINED TO
BE INVALID.
THIS BILL PROVIDES A MUCH NEEDED
MECHANISM TO ASSURE FAIRNESS AND
ALLOW USED TO RECEIVE THE
RESOURCES AND SERVICES THEY NEED
FOR REHABILITATION IN THE
JUVENILE SYSTEM.
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL NOTED
CONCERNS REGARDING SITUATIONS
THAT INCLUDE PLEA BARGAINING WE
ARE TAKING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
TODAY.
AND THE CASE WHERE THERE HAVE
BEEN PLEA AGREEMENTS.
A JUVENILE MAY BE TRANSFERRED
BACK TO JUVENILE COURT WITH THE
AGREEMENT OF THE PROSECUTOR.
WE WE ARE OPEN TO WORKING WITH
THE OPPOSITION TO ADDRESS ANY
CONTINUING CONCERNS.
I WANT TO THANK OUR SPONSORS THE
PACIFIC ALL PACIFIC JUVENILE
DEFENDER CENTER AND INTRODUCE
OUR WITNESS SUPER I'LL AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR THE AYE
VOTE OF THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU MOVE THE BILL.
SECOND.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THIS
BILL DOES ADDRESS A VERY NARROW
GAP THAT WAS IDENTIFIED IN
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT BY THE
COURT OF APPEAL IN.
THE CASE OF PEOPLE VERSUS SELF.
AND THE COURT OF APPEALS SAID
THAT THEY HAD NO ABILITY TO
TRANSFER CASE BACK TO JUVENILE
COURT WHEN THE YOUNG PERSON WAS
CONVICTED OF A LESSER OFFENSE.
AND THAT THIS WAS SOMETHING THAT
THE LEGISLATURE NEEDED TO TAKE A
LOOK AT SO HERE WE ARE TWENTY
YEARS LATER.
BUT BETTER LATE THAN NEVER --
WHAT HAPPENS -- AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WICKS HAS SAID IS THAT
SOMETIMES WHEN THE IN THE
TRANSFER HEARING THE COURT IS
USING THE ARREST REPORT AS THE
BASIS FOR DECIDING TRANSFER.
AND EVEN THOUGH THE COURT LOOKS
AT A SERIES OF FACTORS THE
SERIOUSNESS OF THE OFFENCE
WEIGHS HEAVILY IN THE DECISION
WHETHER TO DETERMINE THAT A
YOUNG PERSON CANNOT BE
REHABILITATED IN THE ADULT
SYSTEM.
SO -- SO AND SO WHAT HAPPENS AND
WHEN THE CASE GETS TO ADULT
COURT AND THERE'S TIME TO
INVESTIGATE AND TALK TO
WITNESSES.
AND THE YOUNG PERSON IS
CONVICTED OF SOMETHING LESS
THERE'S NO WAY TO GET THE YOUNG
PERSON.
BACK TO JUVENILE COURT AND SO AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE PROVIDES
FOR THREE SPECIFIC SITUATIONS
ONE IS WHERE.
THE YOUNG PERSON GOES TO ADULT
COURT AND IS CONVICTED ONLY OF
MISDEMEANORS.
AND YOU WOULDN'T EVEN BE
ELIGIBLE FOR TRANSFER ON
MISDEMEANORS SO THAT ONE IS EASY.
THE SECOND ONE IS WHERE THE
YOUNG PERSON GOES TO ADULT COURT
AND IS CONVICTED STILL OF A
FELONY BUT A MUCH LESS SERIOUS
FELONY.
THAN THAN THE FRANCE FOR
DECISION WAS PREMISED ON AND IN
THAT CASE THIS BILL WILL ALLOW
THE COURT TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE
RECORD OF THE TRANSFER HEARING.
AND IF IT LOOKS LIKE THE OFFENSE
WAS SERIOUSLY A FACTOR IN THE
DECISION TO TRANSFER THE YOUNG
PERSON THE COURT HAS THE ABILITY
IN THE INTERESTS OF JUSTICE TO
TRANSFER THE CASE BACK. TO
JUVENILE COURT FOR DISPOSITION.
THE THIRTY SITUATION IS THE ONE
THAT I THINK IS WHAT --
PERCOLATED THE INTEREST OF THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S ANDTHAT'S
IN THE CASE OF PLEA BARGAINS.
AND WE THINK THAT THEY HAVE A
LEGITIMATE POINT THAT A PLEA
BARGAIN TO A LESSER OFFENSE
COULD BE FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS OTHER THAN JUST THE
SERIOUSNESS OF THE OFFENSE.
AND SO WHAT WE'VE DONE IN THE
AMENDMENTS IS TO REQUIRE THAT
THE COURT MAKE THE DETERMINATION
THAT THE CASE IN THE INTERESTS
OF JUSTICE SHOULD GO BACK.
BUT ALSO REQUIRE THE CONSENT OF
THE PROSECUTOR AND WHEN YOU
REALIZE THAT.
OVER 90% OF CASES ARE RESOLVED
BY PLEA BARGAINS THIS GIVES THE
PROSECUTOR AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF
POWER.
THIS BILL CAME -- TO BECAME TO
YOU BECAUSE OF THE EXPERIENCE OF
PUBLIC DEFENDERS AROUND THE
STATE WHOSE YOUNG CLIENTS ARE
CONVICTED OF A LESSER OFFENSE
AND WIND UP.
GOING TO COUNTY JAIL WHERE THEY
GET NO EDUCATION NO
REHABILITATED SERVICES OR MAY
EVEN BE AN UNSUPERVISED
PROBATION IN THE COMMUNITY.
THIS IS A BAD SITUATION FOR THEM
AND IT'S BAD FOR THE COMMUNITY
AT LARGE WE ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
MARCO GEORGE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
KATHY SURE FOR THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
LUCY SALCEDO CARTER WITH THE
YOUTH LAWCENTER IN SUPPORT.
DOMINIQUE NOW FOR A PUBLIC
DEFENDER AND BEHALF THE
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
DONNA MANDEL ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE AND ARE JUNE JUVENILE
UNIT IN SUPPORT.
JACKIE WILSON SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE STRONG
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SELENA CHAFIN ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION WE SUPPORT.
NORMA COMPOUND FROM THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION AND FULL
SUPPORT.
ALSO GIVE JUSTICE COALITION
TAKE A JACKSON FOR YOU JUST AS
COALITION FOR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
APRIL VANDYKE DEPUTY PUBLIC
DEFENDER FULL SUPPORT.
KIM AGO YOU DISCLOSURE IN
SUPPORT ROSS ONE SUPPORT OF
THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE WHICH JUST
MISSED SO FAR.
THE NEEDS PER PUBLIC DEFENDER
SUPPORT.
ANNA DROOPED IN PUBLIC SCHOOL
TEACHER PULL FULL SUPPORT.
I SPAWNING AS WITH ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
WE ARE ANY WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
BUT AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS LARRY MORSE ON BEHALF
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION -- WE WERE WORKING
WITH -- SIMPLY WOMAN STAFFS MADE
VERY IMPORTANT -- CAM -- CHANGES
IN THE BILL AND WE ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WHEN WE'RE
STILL OPPOSE.
BUT I'D CHARACTERIZE IT IS SOFT.
WHICH MADE A BIG SHE MAY BIG
CONCESSION [inaudible]
YES.
ANY QUESTIONS YEAH JUST A
CLARIFICATION WITH THESE
CONVICTIONS.
SUCH ROOM SET BACK TO THE
JUVENILE SYSTEM FALL UNDER THE
JUVENILE STANDARD AND BE AN
EDUCATION FOUND TRUE AND NOT A A
CONVICTION.
SO THEREFORE NOT BE USED AS A
FIREBALL OFFENSE.
YOU UNDERSTAND MY QUESTION.
I I DON'T I DON'T I'M NOT SURE I
KNOW THE ANSWER I IT THEY WITH
THEIR JUTE THEIR JUVENILE
ADJUDICATIONS.
SO THEY'RE NOT CONVICTIONS IN
THE SENSE OF A NORM OF A YOU
KNOW EMPLOYMENT AND FINANCIAL.
OPPORTUNITIES -- BUT I THINK
THAT THE THE RULES ON PRIOR
RIPPLE COMES UNDER A DIFFERENT
KIND OF CATEGORY OF HOW THAT'S
FIGURED OUT.
OKAY GOOD ENOUGH [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
OF ANY OTHER WITNESSES BUILT
WITH ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
YOU MAY CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
YES.
ON AB FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER.
GEN SIR I LACKEY.
LACKEY NOT VOTING BAUER-KAHAN
[inaudible]
DEEP.
DEEP NOT VOTING KAMLAGER-DOVE HI
KAMLAGER-DOVE I QUIRK
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
WICKS HI WICKS I MEASURES ARE
CALLED NEEDS TO MORE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
NOW MISS [inaudible]
CRISTINA [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS FOR COMPETING WITH WATER
PARKS AND WILDLIFE FOR THE LONG
IS HEARING TODAY [inaudible]
THE LAND.
JUST WRAPPED UP OVER THERE.
I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE CHAIR AND THE STAFF
ARE WORKING ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE.
I ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON FURTHER
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS AND LATER
POLICY IN FISCAL COMMITTEES.
AB FOURTEEN FORTY NINE ENSURES
THAT THE EXPERIENCE THE NEEDS OF
CRIME SURVIVORS IS AT THE CENTER
OF THE VICTIMS COMPENSATION
POLICY.
CRIME SURVEY WERE STILL UP
CALIFORNIA DESERVE TO HAVE
ACCESS TO RESOURCES COMPENSATION
AS WELL AS A JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT
PRIOR TO HIS PREVENTION SCRIBBLE
TATIAN AND RECOVERY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE WILL LIMIT MY COMMENTS AND
ALLOW OUR EXPERTS HERE TO GIVE
YOU SOME MORE DETAILS AND
TESTIMONY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ANDRE PERRY
AND ON THE POLICY ADVOCATE FOR
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE AS WELL AS CRIME
SURVIVORS FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE.
AND WE ARE PROUD TO SPONSOR AB
FOURTEEN FORTY NINE WE HAVE COME
TO THE CAPITAL DAY WITH OVER SIX
HUNDRED SURVIVORS WE HAVE MET
WITH ALL OF YOUR OFFICES WE HAVE
CONSTITUENTS FROM EVERYONE WHO
HAS COME UP -- OVER THE LAST
THREE DAYS -- WE ECHO THE
AUTHORS SENTIMENTS -- AND WE
THINK THE COMMITTEE AND THE
CHAIR FOR WORKING ON AB FOURTEEN
FORTY NINE WITH US.
BY REMOVING THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENT THIS BILL EXPANDS
ACCESS AND ELIMINATES ON AN
UNFAIR AND BERGESEN BARRIER THAT
PREVENTS SURVIVORS FROM
ACCESSING THE SUPPORT THEY ARE
TOUGH ENTITLED TO UNDER THE LAW.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIANS VICTIMS
COMPENSATION BOARD MUST DENY
COMPENSATION IF THE SURVIVOR
DOES NOT COOPERATE WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
HOW THE C. B. CAN USE OTHER
EVIDENCE FROM MEDICAL?
PROVIDERS MEDICAL REPORTS OR
MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS TO
VERIFY THAT A CRIME OCCURRED FOR
SEXUAL ASSAULT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING OFFENSES
BUT NOT FOR OTHER CRIMES.
THERE IS A TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN NATIONAL CRIME
VICTIMIZATION SURVEY FOUND THAT
IT FOUND ONLY 45% OF VIOLENT
VICTIMIZATION IS OUR WERE OVER
REPORTED TO POLICE.
CAL THE C. B. AND TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN ANNUAL REPORT TO THE
FEDERAL OFFICE OF VICTIMS OF
CRIME STATES THAT FAILURE TO
REPORT OFFENSES. TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT WITH THE MOST COMMON
REASON. FOR CLAIM TO NILES AND
THAT'S NEARLY A THOUSAND
SURVIVORS THE COMPENSATION
THAT'S PROVIDED ARE FOR VICTIMS
FOR MENTAL HEALTH CARE MEDICAL
CARE RELOCATION COSTS AND OTHER
COSTS THAT SURVIVORS CAN REALLY
FOCUS ON HEALING.
WE THINK ASSEMBLY WOMAN GARCIA
FOR RECOGNIZING THE VOICES OF
SURVIVORS HAVE BEEN SILENT FOR
TOO LONG AND NOW IS THE TIME TO
PUSH A REAL HONEST NARRATIVE
FROM THE SURVIVORS IN CALIFORNIA.
I RELINQUISH THE REST OF MY TIME
TO A SURVIVOR [inaudible]
NINETEEN GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS TO NEEDS HOLLINS I AM THE
CALIFORNIA STATE DIRECTOR FOR
CRIMES VIRUS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE.
ARE PRESENT AND NETWORK OF CRIME
SURVIVORS HERE IN STATE ABOUT
SEVEN THOUSAND MEMBERS.
OR DIVERSE EXPERIENCES AS
SURVIVORS AND I MYSELF AM ALSO
CRIME SURVIVOR I LOST TWO
BROTHERS TO HOMICIDE -- IN SAN
FRANCISCO CALIFORNIA.
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION BECAUSE I BELIEVE
THE CRIME SURVIVOR VOICES REALLY
DO NEED TO INFORM OUR POLICY
DECISIONS.
AND ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
POLICIES THAT DIRECTLY IMPACT US.
THERE ARE MANY REASONS WHY CRIME
SURVIVORS DO NOT REPORT CRIMES
TO THE POLICE AS SOMETIMES THERE
ISSUES AROUND SAFETY --
RETALIATION REPRISED -- ACCESS --
THE PROCESS OF ACTUALLY GETTING
A POLICE REPORT FILED CAN
SOMETIMES PRESENT OF BARRIERS
AND SAFETY ISSUES FOR CRIME
SURVIVORS AND THAT SHOULD NOT BE
SO.
OF CRIME SURVIVORS INTERACT WITH
A NUMBER OF PROVIDERS IN THEIR
PROCESS.
IN RESPONSE TO A CRIME SOCIAL
WORKERS.
DOCTORS -- MEDICAL PROVIDERS
CASE MANAGERS ALL OF THOSE FOLKS
SHOULD BE EMPOWERED TO BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT THE VIRUS TO THE
PROCESS OF GETTING ACCESS IT
SHOULD NOT HAVE TO BE RESTRICTED.
TO ONLY GETTING A POLICE REPORT
TO BE ABLE TO SUBSTANTIATE AN
INCIDENT THAT HAPPENED TO THEM.
WE ARE BRINGING OUR VOICES -- IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL BECAUSE WE
WANT TO ROUTE TO LIMIT --
RESTRICTIONS TO ACCESS FOR
HEALING HEALING IS AT THE CENTER.
OF REDUCING CRIME IN REDUCING
HARM IN OUR COMMUNITIES SO WE
NEED TO DO WHAT WE CAN TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE ARE NO
RESTRICTIONS TO ACCESSING THOSE
SERVICES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
MOVE THE BILL [inaudible]
SECOND.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
NAME IN ORGANIZATION.
YES HI MY NAME IS TAMERA CITY
TEN I AM FROM STOCKTON
CALIFORNIA.
I'M A VICTIM OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND SEXUAL ASSAULT.
AND I SUPPORT AB [inaudible]
FOURTEEN FORTY NINE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DR
NICOLE CLUB -- I LIVE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO I AM WITH CRIME
SURVIVOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE HI
SUPPORT.
ASSEMBLY BILL OF FOURTEEN FORTY
NINE AND I AM A SURVIVOR MY SON
WAS MURDERED HERE IN SACRAMENTO
THANK NOVEMBER AIMED.
IN ORGANIZATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SASHA
VOTE I'M ALSO HERE FROM
SACRAMENTO AND I'M ALSO A WITH
CSS J. -- I'M ALSO SURVIVOR OF
CRIME AND SUPPORT MY CHILDREN
HAVE RECEIVED VICTIM WITNESS
FUNDS AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME MISSION
EQUAL TODD.
I AM FROM SACRAMENTO -- I LOST
THREE CENTS LAST YEAR TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN I AM A
SURVIVOR AND I AM.
A VICTIM AS WELL NOT SUPPORT A.
B. [inaudible]
FOURTEEN FORTY NINE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS NICOLE
I'M WITH THE STOCKTON CHAPTER OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE AND I SUPPORT AB.
ONE FOUR FOUR NINE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN I'M PASTOR RUBEN LEE
OF STOCKTON CALIFORNIA.
AND ON BEHALF OF THE STOCK
NUMBER ENTER BUT SAFETY AND
JUSTICE MY CONGREGATION AND MY
LOVED ONES WHO NEED THIS WE
SUPPORT.
AB.
ONE FOUR FOUR NINE THANK YOU SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DANNY
MOUNTAINS FROM -- SOUTHEAST LA --
I AM PART OF CALIFORNIA SAFETY
AND JUSTICE AND CRIMES OURS IS
SAFETY JUSTICE AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN I IS SOME AGREED SHE
FROM THE SAN DIEGO OR REGIONAL
INTERFAITH COLLABORATIVE.
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS THE LEAST LIVE A
LOS TWO BROTHERS TO GO BONES ARE
FROM SAN FRANCISCO CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS LEAH SMITH ARE
FROM SAN FRANCISCO AND I'M HERE
TO SUPPORT AUSTIN.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S IN MAY KEY I AM
FROM SERVICES GO I AM A SURVIVOR
OF SEXUAL ASSAULT AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IN A SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME'S CARISSA
RONA I'M WITH CRIME SURVIVORS
FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE MOST OF
THE LOCAL SAFETY SOLUTIONS
PROJECT DIRECTOR WITH
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE.
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
I JUST OF THE GEL OF ON BEHALF
OF CHILDREN THE COALITION FOR
HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS LOS
ANGELES.
AND THAT'S IN AN OFFICIAL
POSITION WILL MAKE SURE TO SEND
IT TO THE OTHER SAID THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JUAN PABLO SHOPPERS
FROM CRIME SURVIVORS FOR SITTING
JUSTICE AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
THE OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE YOU MAY CLOSE.
AT YES THANK YOU I WANT TO THANK
ALL THE SURVIVORS HERE WE
LEGISLATE FROM EXPERIENCE
SOMETIMES IT'S OUR OWN
EXPERIENCE OP INTENSE EXPERIENCE
THAT OTHER SHARE WITH US.
THE SURVIVORS HAVE BEEN SHARING
THEIR EXPERIENCE WITH US AND
THROUGH THAT THIS BILL HAS COME
FORWARD AND SAY SO I THINK THE
FOR THEIR COURAGE AND THEIR WORK.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THIS BILL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU AND I THANK YOU FOR
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE IN
ORDER TO COMMITTEE CHAIR I KNOW
AS YOU MOVE FORWARD.
IF WE HAVE PROBLEMS YOU KNOW THE
FINAL DECISION RESTS WITH THE
THE COMMITTEE SO I THANK YOU FOR
WORKING WITH US -- WITH THAT.
WITH THE MESSAGE THE CARD
COMMITTEES.
MAJORS RECOMMEND AYE.
ON AB FOURTEEN FORTY NINE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER.
GEN SIR I LACKEY I WOULD EXPECT
ALL AYE VOTES TO HELP BUILD THE
COMPENSATION FUND.
LACKEY I BAUER-KAHAN BARRICADE
HAND I DEEP.
DEEP I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I QUIRK
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
WICKS.
THAT MEASURE PASSES THANK YOU
[inaudible]
AND MISS BLENDED.
YOU HAVE.
FIFTEEN FIFTY NINE EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT FOUR WHICH ONE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO DO FIRST.
I MISTER CHAIRMAN WE'RE GOING TO
DO AB EIGHT EIGHT FOUR FIRST
MARQUIS DE OKAY.
IT ALSO HAPPENS TO BE ITEM
NUMBER.
EIGHT THE DOOR DOESN'T OPEN.
THE BIG DOOR.
WHEN EVER YOU'RE READY MISS
MELENDEZ THANK YOU?
COULD YOU CLOSE THE DOOR PLEASE
[inaudible]
SERGEANTS.
NOISY DAY I'M SORRY.
I'M WELL THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THE BILL I UNDERSTAND
YOU HAD A REALLY QUITE NONE OF
THAT AND MORNING SO I'M HERE TO
SPICE THINGS UP FOR YOU.
KIDDING.
SWISS LAUGHED THAT.
THIS WENT AS WE USE MOVE THE MY
CLOSER I SURE I THINK IT PERHAPS
IF THEY CAN GET THAT DOOR CLOSE
IT WOULD BE A LOT EASIER FOR
EVERYONE TO HEAR ME -- MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB EIGHT EIGHT FOUR
WHICH SEEKS TO CLEAN UP
CALIFORNIA'S NEW TIERED SEX
OFFENDER REGISTRY.
THE NEW TIERED SEX OFFENDER
REGISTRY ASSIGNS DIFFERENT
REGISTRATION REQUIREMENTS BASED
UPON THE OFFENSE COMMITTED IN
THE AGE OF THE VICTIM IT WAS
DESIGNED TO RELIEVE CERTAIN
OFFENSES LIKE INDECENT EXPOSURE.
OUT FROM REGISTRATION
REQUIREMENTS.
BETTER LESS HARSH THAN SOME OF
THE MORE SERIOUS OFFENSES THAT
ARE COMMITTED.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS NEW TIERED
SYSTEM HAS A HORRIBLE
INCONSISTENCY AND THE
REGISTRATION REQUIREMENTS FOR
SERIOUS OFFENSES UNDER THIS NEW
TIERED SYSTEM MOLESTING A CHILD
UNDER THE AGE OF FOURTEEN IS
DEAN THE TIER TWO OFFENSE.
WHICH MEANS YOU MUST REGISTER
FOR ONLY TWENTY YEARS THE EXACT
SAME OFFENCE OF MOLESTING A
CHILD WHERE THE VICTIM IS
FOURTEEN OR FIFTEEN YEARS OF AGE.
IS TAKEN MORE SERIOUSLY AND IS
PLACED AS A TIER THREE OFFENSE A
LIFETIME OF REGISTRY.
IN ADDITION TO THIS DISCREPANCY
IT IS EXTREMELY TROUBLING THAT
THE TIERED SYSTEM IS BASED ON
THE RECIDIVISM RATE ASSOCIATED
WITH THE OFFENSE.
RESEARCHERS WIDELY AGREED THAT
RECIDIVISM RATES UNDER ESTIMATE
THE TRUE RECIDIVISM RATES
RECEIPT EXCUSE ME RECIDIVISM
RATES OF SEX OFFENDERS AND IS
ALSO EQUALLY TROUBLING.
THAT RISK ASSESSMENT TOOL WILL
BE USED.
TO WILL CONTRIBUTE TO WHICH TEAR
AND OFFENDER IS A SIGN.
I WANT YOU TO CONSIDER THE JOHN
GARDNER CASE WHO WAS GIVEN A LOW
SCORE OF TWO AFTER MOLESTING A
THIRTEEN YEAR OLD GIRL AND AFTER
BEING RELEASED FROM PRISON JOHN
GARDNER WENT ON TO A DOCKED.
RAPE AND MURDER FOURTEEN YEAR
OLD AMBER DO WHAT AND THEN
CAPTURE RAPE AND MURDER SEVEN
CHERYL CHART CHELSEA KING.
THIS IS WHY WE CANNOT TRUST RISK
ASSESSMENTS WE HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO BE WARY OF
EMBRACING RISK ASSESSMENTS AS
THE MAIN DETERMINANT. FOR HOW
LONG A SEX OFFENDER MUST REMAIN
ON THE DATABASE THIS TIERED
SYSTEM WAS CREATED TO ESTABLISH
EQUITY FOR THE PERPETRATORS THE
SYSTEM HOWEVER ESTABLISHES NO
EQUITY FOR THE VICTIMS -- BY
REQUIRING ONLY TWENTY YEARS
REGISTRATION FROM MOLESTING
YOUNG CHILDREN WE ARE FORGETTING
ABOUT THE CHELSEA KINGS IN THE
AMBER DO WISE OF THE WORLD.
THIS BILL ADDRESSES THAT BY
REQUIRING LIFETIME REGISTRATION
AS A SEX OFFENDER FOR THOSE WHO
MOLESTED UNDER THE AGE OF
FOURTEEN THIS BILL IS SUPPORTED
BY THE CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S.
ASSOCIATION AND MANY OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS HERE TO TESTIFY
TODAY -- IS CATHERINE DELAY TREE
WHO IS WITH THE CULT CALIFORNIA
PROTECTIVE PARENTS [inaudible]
YES MA'AM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS KATHERINE TO LET FROM
CALIFORNIA.
PROTECTIVE PARENTS ASSOCIATION
HERE ON BEHALF OF OUR CO FOUNDER
CONNIE VALENTINE.
WITH THE FOCUS ON SEXUAL
HARASSMENT IN THE WORKPLACE IN
THE ME TOO MOVEMENT WE ARE
REMINDED THAT SEXUAL ABUSE OF
ANY SORT IS UNACCEPTABLE.
WHEN IT IS PERPETRATED AGAINST
CHILDREN IT IS A GROTESQUE LIFE
DESTROYING CRIME?
RAPE CRISIS NETWORK REPORTS THAT
THE YOUNGER THE CHILD THE WORSE
THE ABUSE THE MORE LIKELY THE
CHILD IS TO SUFFER ADDITIONAL
ABUSE.
AND THE ABUSES PERPETRATED FOR
LONGER TIME.
CHILDREN ARE SITTING DUCKS FOR
SEXUAL PREDATORS 25240% OF GIRLS
ARE MOLESTED IN THE U. S. 16230%
OF BOYS ARE MOLESTED IN THE U.
S..
CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES ARE
FOUR TO TEN TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
BE SEXUALLY ABUSED HARVARD
UNIVERSITY IS BLUNTLY
PESSIMISTIC ABOUT PETA FILES.
THE JULY TWENTY TEN HARVARD
HEALTH NEWSLETTER STATES THAT
RESEARCHERS HAVE FOUND NO
EFFECTIVE TREATMENT. FOR
PEDOPHILE YEAH.
THERE IS NO CURE SO THE FOCUS IS
ON PROTECTING CHILDREN STATE
PROGRAMS SUCH AS THE MEGAN'S LAW
AND THE ADAM WALSH ACT SEEK TO
LIMIT WHERE CONVICTED.
CONVICTED SEX CRIME OFFENDERS
MAY LIVE AND WORK THESE PROGRAMS
ALERT THE COMMUNITY AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO POTENTIAL
SUSPECTS.
THERE IS IN EQUITY IN THE
CURRENT CALIFORNIA STATUTE
REGARDING THE TIERED SEX
OFFENDER REGISTRY MEGAN'S LAST
WHEN A PERPETRATOR IS CONVICTED
OF A LEWD OR LASCIVIOUS CRIME
AGAINST A CHILD.
IF THE CHILD IS AGE FIFTEEN OR
SIXTEEN THE CONVICTED OFFENDER
MUST REGISTER FOR LIFE ON
MEGAN'S LIST.
BUT IN THE SAME CRIME IF THE
SAME CRIME IS PERPETRATED ON A
CHILD FOURTEEN YEARS ARE UNDER
THAT DEFENDER ONLY NEEDS TO
REGISTER FOR TWENTY YEARS.
THIS INEQUITY NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED SINCE IT PROVIDES A
HUGE LOOPHOLE. FOR PETA FILES
AND REDUCES PROTECTION FOR
POTENTIAL CHILD VICTIMS AB EIGHT
EIGHT FOUR WOULD RECTIFY THE
DISPARITY IN SEX OFFENDER
REGISTRATION WHILE ENSURING
CHILDREN FOURTEEN YEARS AND
UNDER ARE PROTECTED.
FROM FURTHER PREDATION
CALIFORNIA PROTECTIVE PARENTS
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE ON AB.
EIGHT EIGHT FOUR THANK YOU MA'AM.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
WRITING SHERMAN WITH THE
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
SUPPORT ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
WHAT WHAT RUN HERE?
LET THEM TESTIFY FIRST AND THEN.
WHAT DO TO ME?
TOO YES.
I AM WE ARE TRACKING CONSULTING
PSYCHOLOGISTS AND BOARD
COORDINATOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
SEX OFFENDER MANAGEMENT BOARD.
THE BOARD IS MADE UP OF EXPERTS
IN THE FIELD INCLUDING VICTIM
ADVOCATES ATTORNEYS REPRESENTING
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S PUBLIC
DEFENDERS AND JUDGES COULD YOU
PULL THE MICROPHONE JUST A
LITTLE CLOSER I KNOW IT'S SHE'LL
TELL USED DIFFICULT ALL THE
NOISE.
START OVER.
GO GO PLEASE.
I'M ONLY A CHAIN CAM CONSULTING
PSYCHOLOGISTS IMPORT COORDINATOR
FOR THE CALIFORNIA SEX OFFENDER
MANAGEMENT BOARD.
THE BOARD IS MADE UP OF EXPERTS
IN THE FIELD INCLUDING VICTIM
ADVOCATES ATTORNEYS REPRESENTING
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S PUBLIC
DEFENDERS AND JUDGES LAW
ENFORCEMENT REPRESENTATIVES
INCLUDING INVESTIGATING OFFICERS
CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS PRO
ADMINISTRATORS FROM CDC OUR SEX
OFFENDER ASSESSMENT AND
TREATMENT PROVIDERS.
COUNTY AND CITY ADMINISTRATORS.
THE BOARD OPPOSES AB.
EIGHT EIGHT FOUR THE BOARD WAS
THE LEAD SPONSOR OF SB THREE
EIGHTY FOUR WHICH CHANGE
LIFETIME REGISTRATION TO A
TIERED SYSTEM.
SB THREE EIGHTY FOUR IS BASED ON
CURRENT AND RELIABLE RESEARCH ON
SEXUAL OFFENDER RECIDIVISM RATES
AND SOUND PUBLIC POLICY.
RESEARCH INFORMS US THE LONGER A
SEX OFFENDERS IN THE COMMUNITY
WITHOUT COMMITTING A CRIME THE
LESS LIKELY THEY ARE TO COMMIT A
NEW OFFENSE.
HIGHLIGHTING THAT IF AN AVERAGE
RISK SEX OFFENDER IS IN THE
COMMUNITY FOR TWENTY YEARS
WITHOUT COMMITTING AN OFFENSE.
THERE AT NO GREATER RISK THAN
SOMEONE IN THE GENERAL PUBLIC TO
COMMIT ANY OF SEXUAL OFFENSE.
SB THREE FOUR CREATED A
MECHANISM FOR ADDRESSING HIGHER
RISK OFFENDERS WHO COMMIT PC.
TO EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHT
INDIVIDUALS ASSESS TO BE IT WELL
ABOVE AVERAGE RISK OF RE
OFFENDING ON THE STATIC NINETY
NINE OUR RISK ASSESSMENT TOOL
WILL BE PLACED ON TIER.
THREE OR IF THE CONVICTED SEX
OFFENDER COMMITS ANOTHER SEX
CRIME UNDER REGISTRATION HERE
SHE WILL BE MOVED FROM TIER TWO
TO TIER.
THREE THE BOARD BELIEVES THAT
THE STRUCTURE OF THE SOON TO BE
ENACTED TIERED REGISTRATION
SYSTEM IS EFFICIENT AND
EFFECTIVE ARE PROTECTING THE
COMMUNITY.
AND USERS RESEARCH AND PRACTICE
TO BUILD THE MOST BALANCED
MONITORING OF CONVICTED SEX
OFFENDERS.
THANK YOU NEXT -- BARCO GEORGE --
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION.
AND YOU HEARD FROM MY COLLEAGUE
FROM THE CALIFORNIA SEX OFFENDER
MANAGEMENT BOARD FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO MIGHT NOT KNOW THE
CALIFORNIA SEX OFFENDER
MANAGEMENT BOARD WAS CREATED OUT
OF CDC R. TASKFORCE.
WHICH ARE BROUGHT TOGETHER
PAROLE OFFICERS PROBATION
OFFICERS LAW ENFORCEMENT.
ON TO PUBLIC DEFENDERS AND
EVERYONE ELSE WAS EITHER
PSYCHOLOGIST OR LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND BAD -- OUT OF THAT.
CALIFORNIA CDC YOUR TASKFORCE
GREW.
AND WAS MANDATED BY THE
LEGISLATURE THE CALIFORNIA SEX
OFFENDER MANAGEMENT BOARD.
AND THEY WERE SPECIFICALLY
TASKED WITH COMING UP WITH HOW
TO MANAGE SEX OFFENDERS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND BAD IS THE BOARD.
OF THAT MY COLLEAGUE AS PART OF
AND SHE IS A PSYCHOLOGIST ON THE
BOARD AND YOU KNOW PROBABLY
ALREADY THAT THE BOARD IS HEADED
BY NANCY O'MALLEY IS THE CHAIR.
WHO IS THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY OF
ALAMEDA COUNTY?
THE LEGISLATION THAT A.. EIGHT
EIGHT FOUR SIX TO RE.
IS LEGISLATION THAT WAS BROUGHT
BY THE CALIFORNIA SEXISM
OFFENDER MANAGEMENT BOARD
BECAUSE AFTER STUDYING THE
PROBLEM AND THERE WAS AN
ENORMOUS PROBLEM BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA WAS ONE OF THE FEW
STATES IN THE COUNTRY.
THAT HAVE LIFETIME REGISTRATION
FOR EVERYONE -- IT WAS JUST AND
MANAGEABLE.
IT WAS SO BIG IT WAS NOT
PROTECTING PUBLIC SAFETY SO THEY
STUDY THE PROBLEM.
AND THEIR RECOMMENDATIONS WERE
EMBODIED WITH IN SB THREE EIGHTY
FOUR WHICH WAS PASSED TWO YEARS
AGO.
BY MANY OF YOU WERE SITTING HERE
TODAY -- IN ANY EVENT THAT WAS
FOUNDED AND A ROSE OUT OF THE
VERY ROBUST BODY OF SOCIAL
SCIENCE EVIDENCE.
AND THE REASON THAT -- PEOPLE
CHARGE WITH CHILD MOLESTATION
LEWD BEHAVIOR ON CHILDREN WERE
MOVED FROM LIFETIME REGISTRATION
TO TWENTY YEARS WAS BECAUSE THEY
HAVE ONE OF THE LOWEST.
RATES OF RE OFFENSE OF SEXUAL RE
OFFENSE. 86% OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS NEVER RE OFFEND --
AND WHETHER OR AND THAT THEIR
EVALUATED BASED ON THE NUMBER OF
DYNAMIC AND STATIC RISK FACTORS.
I'M NOT GOING TO BELABOR THE
POINT BUT I DO BELIEVE THAT IT
DOES NOT MAKE SENSE. TO UNDER
CUT THIS VERY SOUND POLICY THAT
WAS ENACTED BY THIS BODY JUST
TWO YEARS AGO.
AND HAS NOT YET EVEN BEEN
IMPLEMENTED SO FOR THOSE REASONS
WAS RESPECTFULLY ASKS FOR YOUR
NO VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES
AND SO POOR IN OPPOSITION OF
TARTAN OPPOSITION.
NOW YOU INCOME TO THE MIGHT.
NAME AN ORGANIZATION.
MY NAME IS WE LET THEM SEE
PROMESAS STANISLAUS COUNTY AND
I'M IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL IS DESTROYED ENOUGH
FAMILIES MY MY MY FAMILY HAS
BEEN DESTROYED FOR THIRTY YEARS.
AND I THINK WE ALL DESERVE A
CHANCE THANK WAS SECOND CHANCE
THANK YOU.
WHILE HI -- I JUST LIKE YOU
THANK YOU FOR HAVING.
A HEARING ME TODAY NAME AN ORGAN
MY NAME IS STAN DEMPSEY I'M
SORRY I'M FROM CONTRA COSTA I
MEAN I'M FROM STANISLAUS COUNTY.
AND I BEEN A GOOD PERSON FOR
THIRTY YEARS I'VE BEEN ON THIS
ALMOST THIRTY YEARS IT'S
DESTROYED MY FAMILY.
IS DESTROYED MY YOUR LIFE IS
ISSUE I'VE BEEN A GOOD PERSON I
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU
[inaudible]
HI.
MY NAME IS.
ELIZABETH RELEASE -- I'M FROM
PASADENA CALIFORNIA.
OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND I'M
STRONGLY IN OPPOSITION. TO BET
AB.
EIGHT EIGHT FOUR THANK YOU MA'AM.
NAME ORGANIZATION AND MY NAME IS
REGINA CURVATURE OF LIVE IN
CARMICHAEL CALIFORNIA I AM A
PROUD NATURALIZED CITIZEN.
NON STRANGELY ARE STRICTLY
OPPOSE.
THANK YOU GOD BLESS AMERICA
THANK YOU MA'AM.
LATEST JOAQUIN RODRIGUEZ ON
BEHALF OF MYSELF MY WIFE MY SON
I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB.
EIGHT FOUR THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS JUSTINE COURT AS
MARQUIS AND DOG THAT WAS MY SON.
I SUFFER A LOT I AM A CITIZEN
SACRAMENTO.
TAXPAYER MOTHER [inaudible]
WORKER.
I SUFFER A LOT WITH MY SON.
BECAUSE HE CAN'T PARTICIPATE IN
ANY OF OUR PROGRAMS.
YES STATE AWAY.
AND YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MYRNA EVANS FROM CATS
CARMICHAEL CALIFORNIA.
IN LIGHT STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR BECAUSE IT
DOES NOT GIVE OUR FAMILY A
CHANCE TO RACE ARE A LITTLE.
ONE THE WAY HE DESERVES TO BE
PRAISED BECAUSE KEEN.
IS IN SUCH A BIND WITH THIS AND
NOT GIVEN.
ME AS ACTED WONDERFULLY.
AND YOU KNOW HOW OFTEN AND THE
FOUR PEOPLE BEFORE ME ARE ALL
TOGETHER WE HAVE FAMILY HERE
REPRESENTING.
THIS LITTLE BOY.
WHO IS ALSO A VICTIM?
YOU CAN ROLL YOUR EYES THIS
FALLEN A MAN IS ALSO A VICTIM.
I'M SORRY HIS [inaudible]
EXCUSE ME.
YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION THANK
YOU.
MA'AM HIS NAME AN ORGANIZATION
ONLY.
JAMIE TO FOR A CONCORD
CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE THANK YOU.
ALEXANDER GETTING OUR CLINICAL
FORENSIC SOCIAL WORKER IN LOS
ANGELES I WORK WITH REGISTRANTS
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED TO SPILL.
THANK YOU SIR.
RAFEAL SALAZAR MILL VALLEY
CALIFORNIA ACTUAL ORGANIZATION I
EXTREMELY OPPOSE THANK YOU SIR.
VICTORIA THEY'LL COUGH PALO ALTO
OPPOSED THANK YOU.
EMMETT SMITH SACRAMENTO COUNTY
STRONGLY OPPOSED THANK YOU.
DONNIE APPALLING REDDING
CALIFORNIA YOU GUYS GOT IT RIGHT
THE FIRST TIME NO NEED TO DO
THIS I CERTAINLY OPPOSE.
SACRAMENTO REPRESENTING THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE STRONGLY OPPOSED THANK
YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
GINA REALLY BUT SO FROM
CALABASAS CALIFORNIA AND I VERY
VERY STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS KIMBERLY RELIEF FOOD
SO.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE IT HI BEG
YOU.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS KERRY POSEY I'M FROM
REAL LINDA CALIFORNIA AND I AM
STRONGLY OPPOSED.
THANK YOU.
THERESA MáS FROM SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY STRONGLY OPPOSED THANK
YOU.
FRIDAY GLEE SUNNYVALE CALIFORNIA
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
THIRD THE MON ORANGE COUNTY
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU.
JIM CRAIG SONOMA COUNTY STRONGLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU.
J. SOME MORE -- SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU.
DOUG JURIST SACRAMENTO OPPOSE
DAVE HOUSE EMORY ACCOUNTING
SPAWNING A POSE.
THANK YOU.
BLESS LOZANO SALSA PRINCES
SCHOOL CALIFORNIA IS STRONGLY
OPPOSED THIS.
BILL.
JACKIE WILSON SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
APRIL VANDYKE STRONGLY OPPOSE
[inaudible]
VIEW.
ANNA TO RUBEN CEMETERY -- PUBLIC
SCHOOL TEACHER STRONGLY OPPOSE.
WAS A COURSE ON DECEMBER TALE
COUNTY ON BEHALF OF MY WIFE AND
TWO CHILDREN I OPPOSE.
MARK DRUG IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES BOARD MEMBER FAMILY
SAFETY FOUNDATION I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU SIR.
JANICE BALUCHI ALLIANCE FOR
CONSTITUTIONAL SEX OFFENSE LAWS
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
FRANK ARNETT RIVERSIDE COUNTY
STRONGLY OPPOSED.
MONA MANA X. ALMOST ON A COULD
POLLS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MICHAEL MASANYA.
ELDER OF CALIFORNIA.
MEMBER OF FAMILY CENTER SAFETY
FOUNDATION AND STRONGLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU.
CHARLES LOPEZ OUTGROW STRONGLY
OPPOSE.
THANK YOU.
TRES WHEELER SAN DIEGO COUNTY I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
CHANCE OVERSTAYING Là GONNA GAL
AIR MIND CAN TECHNO AND IMPOSE.
YOUR RECORD MANDERS SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSED.
SABRINA HOW CONCERNED CONCORD
STRONGLY OPPOSED.
DAVID ADLER SANTA CLARA COUNTY
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
RUSSELL ARE CONCERNED POSTS.
I CALL SANTA CLARA POSED.
PETER WILLOWS FROM WITHIN VALLEY
CALIFORNIANS OPPOSE.
WILLIAM THE REALEST MACY SO WELL
AND I OPPOSE -- GLADDEN FREE
INTERROGATION WE OPPOSE.
GREAT CONTROL STRONGLY OPPOSE
FROM LA COUNTY.
STEVE CANTRELL STRONGLY OPPOSE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
MARY HARRON EL DORADO COUNTY
PLEASE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
FOR DAVID HERE ON EL DORADO
COUNTY PLEASE OPPOSE THIS BAD
BILL.
UP TO MORE SAN DIEGO COUNTY
OPPOSE.
LESLIE ARMSTRONG SAN FRANCISCO
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
KNOWLES SANTOS HUNTINGTON BEACH
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
NEXT [inaudible]
NEXT.
BRING A MIKE TOUR OR LOSS SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY STRONGLY OPPOSE AND
AGREE WITH THE SEX OFFENDER
MEDICALLY PORT.
GO IT HI AM HEATHER MALIN I'M
HERE FROM SAN JOSE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
SINGLE HAS.
THE RAY RICHARDS AYE OPPOSED
THANK YOU HAVE HER DAUGHTER MY
BROTHER I STRONGLY OPPOSE AND
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE FOR US
[inaudible]
NEXT.
DAVID WHAT HAD PASADENA
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK
YOU.
BOB HARTLEY SAN PEDRO CALIFORNIA
A STRONGLY OPPOSE.
MIKE GRIFFIS CROTHERS CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
LEADER COULD DERIVE FROM
SACRAMENTO YOU STRONGLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU. ZERO WOULD DELIVER
WITHOUT ALL COUNTY -- I TOTALLY
OPPOSED TO THANK YOU.
FRANKLIN Z. GROVER BEACH
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSE.
DOUG AND LONG HI OPPOSE FROM THE
POMMEL [inaudible]
TYRONE BROWN. FOR SAM CISCO I
PULLED.
JUSTIN SMITH FROM STUDIO CITY
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE.
KATHY SURE FOR THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION.
SAY YOU'RE HANNAH LOS ANGELES
COUNTY I OPPOSE.
RING CORPORAL KIND OF JAMES LOS
ANGELES STRONGLY OPPOSE.
PACKAGE AROUND SACRAMENTO COUNTY.
CONCERNED CITIZEN I STRONGLY
OPPOSE.
ALLEN SALAS DOWNEY CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
ADAM HOCHBERG BURBANK CALIFORNIA
I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
MICHAEL NEWMAN ORANGE COUNTY I
STRONGLY OPPOSE COUNTY I
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
EVAN PEDIA ORANGE COUNTY I
CAN YOU RESIDENT ELDORADO COUNTY
IS STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THE RIGHT COLOR FROM YELLOW
COUNTY STRONGLY OPPOSE.
ROGER ANY GOOD BUSINESSMAN FROM
MODESTO STRONGLY OPPOSE.
MEDI HIRED ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CIVIL LIBERTIES
ADVOCACY AND STRONG OPPOSITION.
JOE SIMONSSON LOMPOC CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY OPPOSED.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESS IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE -- SO
THE AVERAGE -- CHILD MOLESTER
OFFENDS.
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED TIMES BEFORE
THEY EVER CAUGHT IF THEY'RE
CAUGHT.
IF THEY'RE CAUGHT.
ACCORDING TO FBI STATISTICS ONLY
ONE OUT OF EVERY TEN BY THEIR
ESTIMATES ONLY ONE OUT OF EVERY.
TEN IS EVEN REPORTED.
SO THE SUGGESTION THAT. 86%
NEVER RE OFFEND.
I DON'T EVEN UNDERSTAND WHERE
THAT STATISTIC CAME FROM BECAUSE
I DON'T KNOW HOW ANYBODY COULD
POSSIBLY KNOW THAT.
WHAT I DO KNOW IS THAT
CHILDREN'S LIVES ARE RUINED WHEN
THIS HAPPENS?
WE'VE HEARD A LOT OF PEOPLE TALK
ABOUT THE EFFECT THAT HAS ON THE
OFFENDER AND THE OFFENDER'S
FAMILY AND I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT THAT MUST
BE.
SOMETHING DIFFICULT TO DEAL WITH
AS YOU TRY TO MOVE THROUGH YOUR
LIFE.
BUT WE SET CERTAIN PARAMETERS ON
SOCIETY AND HOW WE EXPECT PEOPLE
TO BE HAD.
IN THEIR FREEDOM.
THIS BILL DOESN'T THROW OUT THE
LAW WHOLESALE ONLY CHANGES ONE
PORTION OF IT JUST ONE PORTION.
IT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE BUT IF
YOU MOLEST A CHILD. FOURTEEN OR
FIFTEEN THAT YOUR PUNISHMENT IS
DIFFERENT THAN IF THE CHILD IS
UNDER FOURTEEN IT JUST DOESN'T
MAKE ANY SENSE TO ME
[inaudible]
SO.
THE WAY I'M LOOKING AT THIS IN
THE WAY YOU SHOULD BE LOOKING AT
THIS TO FRANKLY IS.
THIS MEANS THAT.
PARENTS GRANDPARENTS COMMUNITY
MEMBERS.
ARE ABLE TO NOW.
WHO HAS SOMETHING IN THEIR PAST?
THAT WOULD WARRANTED THEM TO BE
A LITTLE MORE CAUTIOUS AROUND
THAT PERSON.
THAT MEANS THAT.
IF YOU KNOW THAT THE NICE MAN
THAT LIVES DOWN THE STREET FROM
YOU WHO'S A SENIOR CITIZEN WHO'S
RETIRED WHO'S ALWAYS OUT WALKING
HIS DOG IN SEEMS FRIENDLY ENOUGH.
YOU SHOULD PROBABLY KNOW.
IF HE HAS SOMETHING LIKE THAT IN
HIS PAST BEFORE YOU ASK HIM TO
BABY SIT.
YOUR TWO YEAR OLD TODDLER WHO
CAN'T TALK AND CAN'T COMMUNICATE
TO YOU WHAT HE MAY.
BE DOING TO HER WHEN YOU'RE NOT
AROUND.
WE ALL KNOW CHILD MOLESTERS ARE
NOT LIKE SOMEBODY IN A DARK
TRENCH COAT WITH GLASSES AND A
HAT ON HIDING IN THE CORNER.
MOST OF THE TIMES IT'S SOMEONE
ALMOST ALL OF THE TIME IT'S
SOMEONE THAT THEY NOW IT IS NOT
A STRANGER IT'S SOMEONE WHO
DEVELOPS A REPORT A RELATIONSHIP
WITH THAT CHILD.
THAT'S WHY THEY'RE SO VULNERABLE
BECAUSE THEY'RE SO GOOD AT IT
AND THEY'RE SO MANIPULATIVE INTO
GETTING PEOPLE TO THINK THAT
THEY ARE PERFECTLY SAFE AND WHAT
I AM SAYING IS I'M NOT ASKING.
THAT THEY ARE THROWN BEHIND BARS
FOR THE REST OF THEIR LIVES THEY
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO LIVE
THEIR LIVES AND BE PRODUCTIVE
CITIZENS AND NO ONE'S GOING TO
STOP THEM FROM DOING THAT.
BUT I DO THINK WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE SURE WE
ARE ALL AWARE.
OF THE SITUATION AND MAKE OUR
OWN DETERMINATION I'M NOT I'M
NOT SAYING.
THEY SHOULD BE JUDGED FOR
ETERNITY I'M SAYING WE SHOULD BE
AFFORDED THE OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
MART CHOICES FOR OUR OWN
CHILDREN I'M ASKING FOR ONE
SECTION OF THIS. TO BE CHANGED
THAT'S ALL I'M ASKING.
FOR WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU -- I KNOW THIS IS A
PASSIONATE.
CONCERN OF YOURS AND SO -- I
KNOW I'M ASKING.
WE HAVE A RISK ASSESSMENT SYSTEM
THAT WILL BE IMPLEMENT IT FAIRLY
SOON.
AND DAY THE THE PREMISE THE
NOVICES ARE VERY SENSITIVE.
ABOUT RISK ASSESSMENT.
AND TO JUST THROW OUT RISK
ASSESSMENT ALTOGETHER WHEN IT
PROBABLY WILL BE [inaudible]
BASED.
PRIMARILY ON WHAT WE DO WITH
BAIL LETTING PEOPLE OUT TO BE
VERY IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF IT.
SO.
ONE WOULD LIKE TO SEE WHAT WE'VE.
THOSE OF US THAT WORK REAL HARD
FOR TWO TIERED SYSTEM TO GET IN
PLACE AND YOU WERE HERE AND I
WERE HERE HOW HARD IT WAS EVEN
JUST.
TO GET THAT VOTED IN THE WEEKLY
SLATED GET IMPLEMENTED BECAUSE
OF THEIR A LOT OF PEOPLE TOOK
SOME VERY VERY VERY TOUGH VOTE.
ON IT ISSUE -- TO TO HAVE THAT
EVEN START SO LET'S GET THAT
STARTED.
AND THEN IS BEFORE WE START
WATERING IT DOWN.
THAT'S ONE TO LET'S SEE HOW THE
RISK ASSESSMENT AND OTHER TOOLS
ARE BEING USED TO ASSESS THESE
INDIVIDUALS TO SEE IF IT
ACTUALLY WORKS AND MAKE THINGS
BETTER SO WE DON'T.
SO WE ABSOLUTELY DON'T PUT.
ANYONE AT RISK NO MATTER WHAT
AGE.
AND SO WITH THAT -- THE CHURCH
RECOMMEND NO VOTE [inaudible]
SECOND.
ON AB EIGHT FOUR THE MOTION IS
TO PASS THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
JONES SAWYER.
CHEN SERRANO LACKEY.
LACKEY I BAUER-KAHAN.
BAUER-KAHAN I DEEP.
DEEP I KAMLAGER-DOVE HAVE NO
KAMLAGER-DOVE NO QUIRK
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
WICKS.
MEASURES ON CALL NEEDS TO MARK.
AND YOU HAVE YOUR OTHER BILL.
I DO I HAVE AB [inaudible]
ONE FIVE FIVE NINE AND LOOKING
FOR MY WITNESS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE IN HERE SO YEAH
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE HERE --
IT RYAN SHERMAN IS STILL IN THE
ROOM.
GOOD INDIAN RE OKAY PERFECT
PERFECT OKAY.
THANK YOU GENTLEMEN.
A LETTER YOU WROTE MOST OF THEM.
I KNOW WHY I DIDN'T KNOW I
BROUGHT MOST OF THEM.
TURNS OUT I KNOW HOW TO THROW A
PARTY SOUTH.
OKAY.
SO -- MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WHILE
EVERYONE IS GETTING SETTLED I'M
HERE TO PRESENT AB ONE FIVE FIVE
NINE ON THIS IS A BILL ABOUT THE
SECOND AMENDMENT WHICH IS YOUR
FAVORITE AMENDMENT I KNOW.
I'M SO I HOPE THAT YOU ENJOY MY
PRESENTATION THIS MORNING.
THE LEGISLATION BEFORE YOU TODAY
NOT ONLY UPHOLD THE SECOND
AMENDMENT BUT IT PROTECTS THOSE
WHO ARE THE MOST VULNERABLE AND
THE MOST IN FEAR OF THEIR LIVES
NOW MORE THAN EVER.
CALIFORNIANS HAVE SEEN AN
INCREASE IN VIOLENT THREATS IN
VIOLENT CRIMES THE MOST RECENT
CRIME DATA REPORT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
SHOWS.
THAT OVER ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
RELATED CALLS ARE MADE IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WHICH IS A 3%
INCREASE SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT THE AMOUNT OF
RAPE CASES IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
NEARLY DOUBLED SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT THESE VICTIMS
CANNOT PROTECT THEMSELVES
BECAUSE A BIG GOVERNMENT
BUREAUCRACY THAT WE HAVE IN
PLACE.
CALIFORNIA LAW STATES THAT IN
ORDER FOR A PERSON TO RECEIVE A
CONCEALED CARRY PERMIT THE CAT
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE MUST PROMPTLY FURNISH A
BACKGROUND CHECK INSTEAD THE
LICENSING AUTHORITY A REPORT OF
THE DATA.
RIGHT NOW THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO APPLY FOR CCW
WAIT MONTHS OR EVEN YEARS I'M ON
THE STATUS OF THEIR PERMIT
BECAUSE DOJ TAKES SO LONG TO
PROCESS THEIR COME THERE --
THEY'RE FILING SOME SHARES IN
POLICE DEPARTMENTS HAVE ALSO
ALLOWED A PERMIT APPLICATIONS TO
OVERFLOW I KNOW THAT HAPPENED IN
MY OWN COUNTY WORK COUNTY
SHERIFF.
ALLOWED THESE APPLICATIONS A
PILOT FOR FOR TWO YEARS AND
PEOPLE HAD TO WAIT AND WAIT AND
WAIT.
THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD NOT ALLOW
BUREAUCRACY TO STAND IN BETWEEN
VICTIMS OF VIOLENCE IN THE RIGHT
TO PROTECT THEMSELVES THIS BILL
MEERS WHAT OTHER STATES DO.
ALLOWS A PERSON HE REASONABLY
BELIEVES THAT THEY'RE IN DANGER
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SEXUAL
ASSAULT OR STOCKING TO APPLY FOR
A THIRTY DAY TEMPORARY CONCEALED
CARRY EMERGENCY LICENSE.
AFTER SATISFYING ALL THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE ORDINARILY
I HAVE TO BE MET FOR CCW THERE
IS NO SPECIAL PASSED GIVEN HERE
IT'S JUST SAYING IT WILL BE
EXPEDITED.
I DON'T BELIEVE AND I DON'T I
HOPE YOU DON'T EITHER THAT THE
GOVERNMENT SHOULD STAND IN THE
WAY THE DEMS PROTECTING
THEMSELVES SO WITH ME TODAY IS
RAIN SHERMAN FROM THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
INDIAN READ FROM YOUR FAVORITE
ORGANIZATION THE NRA.
THANK YOU.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS RYAN
SHERMAN WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION -- ARE
RIVERSIDE COUNTIES AS SENSUALLY
THE SIZE OF NEW JERSEY AND WE'RE
VERY SPARSELY POPULATED IN A LOT
OF AREAS.
AND LOTS OF FOLKS ARE IN
DESPERATE NEED OF BEING ABLE TO
PROTECT THEMSELVES WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH STAFF.
OUT IN THESE FRINGE PARTS OF THE
COUNTY.
AB FIFTEEN FIFTY NINE WILL ALLOW
SPECIFIED IN DANGER PERSONS TO
BE BETTER POSITIONED. TO PROTECT.
THEMSELVES AND THEIR FAMILIES BY
ALLOWING THEM TO APPLY. FOR
EMERGENCY CCW UNDER LIMITED
CIRCUMSTANCES.
THIS BILL ALLOWS THEM TO APPLY
FOR IT IT DOESN'T REQUIRE THAT
THEY ACTUALLY BE ISSUED.
ONE SO IF THEY DON'T MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE BILL THEY
WOULD NOT END UP GETTING THE
PERMIT -- THE RESEARCHER
ASSOCIATION IS.
PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS BILL WE
THINK IT'S GOING TO LEAD TO
IMPROVED.
SAFETY FOR THE PERSONS THAT ARE
BEING STOCKED OR ARE POTENTIAL
VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
WE THINK IT IS A GOOD WAY FOR
PEOPLE TO DEFEND THEMSELVES WHEN
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH LAW
ENFORCEMENT AROUND.
AND WE ARE JR YES VOTE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE RECORD AND
RE WITH NATURAL FORCES YOU
SHOULD ALSO DOING ME TOO FOR
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
TODAY.
WE WANT TO THINK THE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN FOR BRINGING THIS GREAT
PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
THAT WILL HELP THOSE WHO ARE IN
IN GREAT DANGER OF OF CERTAIN
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SEXUAL SOLDIER
STOCKING SITUATIONS -- AS YOU
JUST HEARD FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT
THEY CAN'T BE EVERYWHERE AT
EVERY TIME.
AND SOMETIMES A RESTRAINING
ORDER IS JUST NOT ENOUGH TO
PROTECT THEM FROM WOULD BE
AGGRESSORS AND ATTACKERS.
AND SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT
PROVIDES A CLEAR PATH. FOR
EMERGENCY AND EXPEDITED
CONCEALED CARRY PERMITS ALL THE
SAME LAWS ARE GOING TO APPLY
OTHER THAN YOU HAVE THE
EMERGENCY PERMIT -- LAW
ENFORCEMENTCAN'T CHECK TO MAKE
SURE THEY'RE NOT PROHIBITED AND
WE KNOW THAT THEY THERE IS A
MECHANISM FOR THE THAT TO DO
ALMOST INSTANTANEOUSLY BY THE OP
SYSTEM AS WELL AS THE AS HE
LEADS SYSTEM I BELIEVE IS WHAT'S.
IN THIS BILL WE'RE GONNA SEE
THAT AYE AMMUNITION COMING UP
HERE IN A FEW MONTHS -- SO RIGHT
NOW CONCEALED CARRY PERMITS IN
ORDER TO JUST GETTING A PERMIT
TO OUR AN APPLICATION TO APPLY
CAN TAKE WEEKS MONTHS AND IN
SOME CASES ALL YEARS -- WHICH IS
JUST NOT CUTTING IT AND SO THIS
PROVIDES A CLEAR PATH NO RIGHT
NOW IN EXISTING LAW THERE IS AN
EXEMPTION. FOR SOMEONE WHO'S
ENGRAVER IMMEDIATE DANGER TO
CARRY A CONCEALED FIREARM.
HOWEVER THAT'S THAT'S TREATED
MORE AS AN AFFIRMATIVE DEFENSE
SO IN THE EVENT THAT SOMEONE
FEELS THAT THEY'RE IN.
I MEDIA OR GRAVE DANGER AND
THEY'RE CARRYING A CONCEALED
FIREARM THAT'S KIND OF AN
EVOLVING SITUATION COULD BE OPEN
TO INTERPRETATION AND IT COULD
COST.
US SOMEONE WHO DOES FEAR FOR
THEIR LIFE I TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS IN LEGAL FEES
PLEADING THIS AFFIRMATIVE
DEFENSE.
WE THINK THIS IS A GREAT BILL I
THINK IT'S GONNA GO A LONG WAY
FOR PUBLIC SAFETY AND WE THINK
THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN AGAIN FOR
BRINGING IT.
THANK YOU.
ARE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
THIS GERMAN MEMBER SAMPRAS
REPRESENTING DOLLARS CALIFORNIA
AND THE NATIONAL SHOOTING SPORTS
FOUNDATION IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
DEMOCRATS CRP AND ARE A MEMBER
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN.
SUPPORT.
YES MA'AM.
CATHERINE TO LET SURVIVOR OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE IS IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
IF [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
IT'S NOT EVENING AT EMENTA
WILCOX HERE ON BEHALF OF BRADY
CALIFORNIA KIND OF RIGHT THAT
TIME -- IN NO WAY DO I INTEND TO
BE DISMISSIVE OF VICTIMS OR
POTENTIAL VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. FOR THOSE OP FACING
POSSIBLE SEXUAL ASSAULT OR
STALKING I DO NOT WANT TO MAKE
LIGHT OF THAT -- HOWEVER I DO
FIND THIS BILL TROUBLING.
BY MY READING OF THE BILL -- A
SHARE FOOT ESSENTIALLY BE
REQUIRED TO ISSUE IN AND
IMMEDIATELY AN EMERGENCY LICENSE
THE BILL SAYS THAT THEY MAY.
DOESN'T SAY SHALL.
OUR CONDUCTOR BACKGROUND CHECKS
NO TRAINING IS REQUIRED IN AS A
RESOLVE.
THERE ARE A BE A PERSON WHO IS
AFRAID.
ON TRAIN CARRYING -- A LOT OF
FIREMAN PUBLIC I THINK THAT'S A
RECIPE FOR DISASTER I THINK IT'S
INTERESTING TO NOTE.
THAT -- TO MY KNOWLEDGE NO
CALIFORNIA DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
OUR PREVENTION.
COALITION MEMBER ORGANIZATION IS
IN SUPPORT OF THAT BILL -- AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE FINDING
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY THERE HAS
BEEN A PUSH BY THE GUN LOBBY. TO
ARM TO MISSED DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
VICTIMS WITH THESE EMERGENCY
ORDERS ARE THERE BEEN MANY
STATEMENTS BY DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
RESEARCHERS AND EXPERTS --
STATING THAT -- HOW AND WHY IS
THAT IS THAT IF YOU PUT FIREARMS
IN THE HANDS OF UNTRAINED AFRAID
PERSON THAT'S A RECIPE FOR
DISASTER SOMEONE IS LIKELY BE
HURT -- THE POTENTIAL EFFECT --
THE OFFENDER -- OR CHILDREN
[inaudible]
INVOLVED [inaudible]
LEAVING.
YOU'RE KIDDING.
I DO NOT HAVE A ISSUE WITH --
AND EXPLICATED EXPEDITED PROCESS
FOR CCW BY THINK DIMMER
EMERGENCY -- OUR PERMIT IS
UNWISE AND PUTS.
THE FAMILY MEMBERS THE POTENTIAL
VICTIM AND THE PUBLIC ADDRESS.
AT ASKS FOR YOUR NO VOTE THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
OKAY.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
YOU MAKE.
CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBER LACKEY HE WAS
STILL WITH US -- I WANT TO
ADDRESS A COUPLE OF THINGS THAT --
WERE STATED BY ONE OF THE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION THIS
BILL DOES NOT REQUIRE.
THAT THE PERMIT IS ISSUED NO
WE'RE IN THE BILL DOES IT SAY
THAT IS REQUIRED THAT IS I DON'T
KNOW WHAT SHE'S READING BUT IT'S
NOT MY BILL -- AND I TAKE.
A LITTLE BIT OF ISSUE WITH HER
WHEN IT SEEMS LIKE A SUGGESTION
THAT A GUN GROUP -- THIS IS
AGAIN GROUPS BILL THIS WAS
ACTUALLY MY IDEA AND MY BILL --
AND AS YOU RECALL NOT SO LONG
AGO ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR I
SHARED WITH YOU IN THE REST OF
MY COLLEAGUES THE STORY.
OF MY OWN MOTHER.
WHEN SHE WAS GOING THROUGH A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ISSUE WHEN I
WAS A YOUNG CHILD AND HER NEED?
TO BORROW A WEAPON FROM SOMEONE
WHICH ULTIMATELY SAVED HER LIFE
SHE ENOUGH TO FIRE THAT WEAPON
BUT THAT WEAPON ULTIMATELY SAVED
HER LIFE THAT IS WHERE THE IDEA
FROM THIS FOR THIS BILL COMES
FROM.
BY MIDNIGHT THIS EVENING THREE
WOMEN JUSTIN SIGNO GO CAN SEEN
DIEGO COUNTY ALONE WE'LL BE
RIGHT.
THAT'S THE AVERAGE EVERYDAY AT
LEAST THREE WOMEN EVERY DAY IN
SAN DIEGO COUNTY WILL BE RIGHT
THREE WOMEN WILL BE [inaudible]
BRUTALLY ASSAULTED.
IN FRONT OF PERHAPS THEIR
CHILDREN. THREE WOMEN WILL HAVE
THEIR DIGNITY STRIPPED FROM THEM.
THEIR SAFETY AND SECURITY GONE
FOREVER IN YEARS AND YEARS OF
EMOTIONAL SUPPORT THAT IS NEEDED
AND COUNSELING AND INABILITY TO
INTERACT WITH HER HUSBAND OR
SPOUSE OR PARTNER IN IN WAYS
THAT TO THE REST OF US MIGHT
SEEM NORMAL.
IN.
BY MIDNIGHT TONIGHT [inaudible]
SO.
I UNDERSTAND THAT NOT EVERYBODY.
BELIEVES THAT GUN OWNERSHIP IS
IS THE ANSWER RIGHT I CAN
RESPECT THAT.
I DON'T WANT ANYBODY THAT'S NOT
COMFORTABLE WITH THE WEAPON HAVE
ONE FRANKLY BECAUSE THAT IS
DANGEROUS.
BUT I DO WANT THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
IN FEAR OF THEIR LIVES YOU HAVE
IMMEDIATE DANGER TO AT LEAST
HAVE THE CHANCE. TO SAVE THEIR
OWN LIFE.
RATHER THAN HAVE A COMMITTEE OF
LEGISLATORS TELL THEM NO WE
DON'T THINK THAT THAT'S THE
RIGHT OPTION FOR YOU.
I GUESS THEY CAN JUST CALL THE
POLICE AND WAIT.
OR MAYBE THEY WON'T CALL THE
POLICE BECAUSE MAYBE THEY WILL
BE ABLE TO BECAUSE BY THEN WILL
BE TOO LATE.
THIS THIS IS A VERY REASONABLE
BILL. FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
GREAT DANGER.
WHAT HOW HOW ELSE I'M FIVE FOOT?
TWO HOW DO I DEFEND MYSELF
AGAINST SOMEBODY WHO'S SIX FOOT
TWO AND WEIGHS TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY POUNDS HE'S BIGGER THAN
ME HE'S STRONGER THAN ME.
HOW DO I PROTECT MYSELF FROM
SOMEONE LIKE THAT?
IF I KNOW THAT HE'S STALKING ME
IF I KNOW THAT HE'S COMING AFTER
ME IF HE'S ALREADY MADE THREATS
TO ME.
THERE IS NO WAY FOR ME TO DO
THAT.
THERE'S NO WAY FOR ME TO DO THAT.
AND NOT IN.
REJECTING THIS BILL MEANS YOU
ARE RELEGATING.
MILLIONS OF WOMEN. TWO POTENTIAL
DEATH OR OR OR OR SERIOUS
PHYSICAL INJURY.
AS A RESULT OF THE THREAT TO
HAVE BEEN MADE TO THEM.
THIS IS A WOMEN'S RIGHTS ISSUE.
WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR ABOUT.
OKAY SO -- A READING FROM
[inaudible]
YOUR BILL [inaudible]
SECTION.
ONE ON PAGE.
THREE NUMBER THREE AND I DON'T
SEE.
A SHERIFF'S SHALL.
UPON RECEIPT OF AN APPLICATION
PURSUANT TO THIS SECTION
[inaudible]
IMMEDIATELY.
AND WITHOUT DELAY ISSUE TO THE
PERSON.
A TEMPORARY LICENSE TO CARRY A
PROVIDED YOU MEET ALL OF THE
STANDARDS THAT HAVE TO BE MET.
I'M TALKING [inaudible] TO THE
SHARE OF THE SHERIFF SHALL NOT.
PRIOR TO THE ISSUANCE OF THE
EMERGENCY LICENSE.
INVESTIGATE THE BACKS OR THE
VERACITY OF THE AFFIDAVIT.
WHICH MEANS YOU WILL ALLOW
PROHIBITED PERSONS FROM.
BEING CHECKED ON WHETHER THAT
I'M READING FROM YOUR BILL.
SO YOU GET ALL YOUR RIGHTEOUS
INDIGNATION THAT YOU WANT BUT
I'M [inaudible]
AT LEAST.
MISTER CHAIRMAN PLEASE AT LEAST
STATE THE FACTS THAT'S WHY I
CAN'T I CAN'T SECOND IS AFTER MR
LACKEY.
BUT I'M I'M ASSUMING HE'S GOING
TO DO THAT.
BECAUSE BECAUSE THAT'S NOT IN
HERE TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
INDIVIDUAL IS TELLING THE TRUTH.
BUT MORE IMPORTANT SO.
I'M WAITING FOR A MOTION
[inaudible]
THE WELL.
MISTER CHAIRMAN IF I MAY YOU
KNOW THERE'S NO SECOND SOLD.
THOSE COMMITTEE TO BUILD.
THE BILL'S HELD IN COMMITTEE FOR
LACK OF A SECOND.
SO YOU DON'T WANT TO HEAR WHAT I
HAVE TO SAY.
THAT'S IT IT'S HELD IN COMMITTEE
FOR LACK OF A SET [inaudible]
THE YEAH.
BONTA STUFF I MAKE.
YEAH.
I MAY HAVE TO GO.
TO CHIEF.
AMONG.
THEM BILL EARLIEST WILLINGNESS.
DID ANY ADDITIONAL -- WHOA WHOA
WHOA.
POINT OF CLICK.
YEAH.
YEAH THE FIRE [inaudible]
SELECT [inaudible]
YEAH.
THIS.
ONE IN FAILED IS BEING HELD IN
COMMITTEE.
THERE IS NO RECONSIDERATION IS
BEING HELD IN COMMITTEE -- OKAY
WE HAVE REVENUE.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE TO WAIT UNTIL
WE AT OTHERS OF IF YOU WANT WE
CAN GENERATION.
YES YES YOU WILL GET
RECONSIDERATION ON THE PREVIOUS
BILL IF IT FAILS [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
HELP.
I'M HAVING SERGEANTS LOOK FOR
SOME.
OTHER MEMBERS [inaudible] SIX TO
BE ON THE COMMITTEE.
SO WE DON'T HAVE A REAR CURRENT
.
I KNOW YOU LEFT BUT MISSED
MURATSUCHI JUMP ON UP TO WE TRY
TO GET THIS.
IS THIS MOVE THE BILL WITH WITH --
AMENDMENTS OR YES MOVE THE BILL
WITH THE MOMENT [inaudible]
SEC.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR -- SO -- I AM ACCEPTING
THAT MOMENTS AS MOCKED UP IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AS AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS THE AMENDMENTS REMOVE
THE VIDEOTAPING PROVISIONS OF
THE ORIGINAL BILL.
AS WELL AS THE BAN ON GUN
DEALERS SELLING WEAPONS FROM
THEIR HOMES WITH THESE
AMENDMENTS I JUST CONFIRM THAT
THE ACLU IS REMOVING THEIR
OPPOSITION.
AB TEN SIXTY FOUR IS A BILL
SPONSORED BY THE BRADY CAMPAIGN
AGAINST GUN VIOLENCE TO CRACK
DOWN ON BAD ACTOR GUN DEALERS.
WHO ARE THE LEADING SOURCE OF
GUNS ON THE BLACK MARKET WHILE
OUR STATE HAS ENACTED LAWS IN
THE PAST TO REGULATE GUN DEALERS?
FEDERAL AND STATE GOVERNMENTS
HAVE LIMITED RESOURCES TO
ENFORCE THESE LAWS THIS BILL
PROVIDES THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WITH AN APARTMENT
ENFORCEMENT TOOL BY GIVING THEM
THE AUTHORITY TO IMPOSE IMPOSE A
CIVIL FINE OF UP TO ONE THOUSAND
FIRST TIME VIOLATIONS.
IN UP TO THREE THOUSAND FOR
REPEATED OR EGREGIOUS VIOLATIONS
THIS BILL ALSO FALLS THE LEAD OF
THIRTY TWO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
INCLUDE IN CALIFORNIA INCLUDING
THE SITTING COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES THAT A WRITER REQUIRES
FIRE ARM DEALERS TO PURCHASE
LIABILITY INSURANCE OF ONE
MILLION DOLLARS TO ENSURE THAT
ANY VICTIMS.
OF THEFT SALE LEASE OR TRANSFER
OF A FIREARM OR AMMUNITION BY
GUN DEALER WOULD BE COMPENSATED
FOR THEIR LOSS.
I AM JOINED HERE WITH ME AMANDA
**** FROM THE BRADY CAM.
BRADY -- RAIN CALIFORNIA AND
STEVE LONELY FROM BRICK -- BRADY
UNITED.
SO AGAIN AMANDA WILCOX WITH
BRADY CALIFORNIA ONE OF OUR KEY
PROGRAMS FOR NATIONAL OFFICE IS
COMBATING CRIME GUNS IN HOLDING
GUN DEALERS ACCOUNTABLE.
RATHER THAN LISTENING TO ME ON
THIS BILL -- I'D LIKE TO TURN IT
OVER TO STEVE LINLEY WHO IS WITH
OUR BRADY NATIONAL OFFICE IN THE
PROGRAM MANAGER IN LOS ANGELES.
THANK YOU -- GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS STEVE ONLY I'M I'M A
TWENTY SEVEN YEAR VETERAN A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OF THE LAST EIGHT OF
WHICH I SPENT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT JUSTICE.
BUREAU FIREARMS REGULATING
FIREARMS IN CALIFORNIA I'M NOW
WITH AN ACTUAL -- BRADY UNITED
AGAINST A GOVERNESS WANTED TO
TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE THE
CALIFORNIA DOES VERY WELL BUT
HOW WE CAN ENHANCE SOME
ENFORCEMENT.
CURRENTLY IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
A ROBUST.
INSPECTION PROGRAM OF THE
CALIFORNIA LICENSED FIREARM
DEALERS.
HOWEVER THE ONLY THING THAT
THOSE REGULATORS CAN DO.
IS TO ISSUE WARNING LETTERS ADD
TO THE DEALERS THERE'S NO
ENFORCEMENT ACTION THERE IS NO
PENALTY.
FOR AN ACTIVITY THIS BILL WOULD
ALLOW THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE AND THE REGULATORS
THAT WENT IN THERE IS A
VIOLATION.
FROM ONE OF THESE DEALERS
THEY'RE ALLOWED TO SET SOME SORT
OF PENALTY FOR THAT.
AS IT IS RIGHT NOW ALL THE CAN
ASK IS WILL YOU PLEASE MAKE
THESE CHANGES WITH THIS NEW BILL
IT'LL ALLOW THE OTHER APARTMENT
TO TO ENSURE.
THAT THERE ARE SOME COMPLIANCE
WITH THOSE LAWS AND IF NOT THEY
GIVEN OUT FINE THE END
INDIVIDUAL DEALERS THERE'S ALSO
A PROVISION FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE TO HAVE.
A REGULATORY PROCESS IN ORDER TO
HAVE DUE PROCESS FOR THESE
DEALERS.
I PREFER AYE VOTE AND AVAILABLE
FOR QUESTIONS THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
SUPPORT.
I SHOULD TIME ALL ALSO
AUTHORIZED TO EXPRESS IN SUPPORT
OF BAY AREAS FOR STUDENT
ACTIVISTS CALVIN HAD TO CATCH A
TRAIN.
THANK YOU.
IT WOULD IS IN SUPPORT.
KATHY SURE FOR THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA JUST CONFIRMING THAT
WE HAVE REMOVED OPPOSITION AND I
WANTED TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THAT ISSUE.
THANK YOU ANY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
PROTECT [inaudible]
SURE.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SAMPRAS
REPRESENTING GUN WAS CALIFORNIA
AND THE LICENSE CALIFORNIA
FIREARMS DEALER -- BOTH UNDER
WITH THE FEDERAL FIREARMS
LICENSE AND A DEALER UNDER
CALIFORNIA LAW -- THE THE
REQUIREMENT THAT -- FOR FOR
LIABILITY INSURANCE ONE MILLION
DOLLARS IS IS SOMETHING THAT
VIRTUALLY EVERY BUSINESS HAS AND
I KNOW OF NO -- GUN DEALER IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT
DOESN'T HAVE A ONE MILLION
DOLLAR POLICY FOR THE FOR
LIABILITY INSURANCE WHAT THIS
BILL IS CALLING FOR IS NOT A ONE
MILLION DOLLAR -- LIABILITY IT'S
CALLING FOR ONE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR EVERY ACT THAT IS COMMITTED
BY A GUN THAT IS STOLEN -- SOLD
ILLEGALLY OR SOMEHOW GETS OUT OF
THAT ARE OUT OF THAT DEALER
THERE IS NO INSURANCE COMPANY IN
THE WORLD.
THAT WOULD ISSUE A A POLICY LIKE
THAT IN THE AUTHORS STATEMENTS
IN -- IN THE ANALYSIS THE TALKS
ABOUT -- YOU KNOW FOR FOR
LIABILITY FOR DAMAGES RESULTING
FROM DEFECTIVE PRODUCTS WHICH
RUN ON CRIMINAL MISCONDUCT
ANOTHER ACTIONS THAT ARE
DIRECTLY RESPONSIBLE -- FOR FOR
THE MISUSE OF THESE FIREARMS.
NO INSURANCE POLICY IS GOING TO
COVER CRIMINAL -- ACT BY BY
SOMEBODY WHO WHO HAS THE THE THE
POLICY SO -- IF IF THIS IS A
BILL THAT WANTS TO PUT.
GUN DEALERS OUT OF BUSINESS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA BECAUSE
THEY CANNOT COMPLY.
WITH THE REQUIREMENTS OF THIS
BILL TO FIND THIS KIND OF
INSURANCE POLICY THAT DOESN'T
EXIST.
THIS BILL WILL DO JUST THAT.
AND IT WILL ACCOMPLISH NOTHING
AND BY THE WAY.
GUN DEALERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A FEW WAS BAD
ACTORS OF ANY STATE GUN DEALERS --
NATION WIDE REPORTED REGULARLY --
THE KINDS OF BAD ACTORS THAT
WERE MENTIONED BY THE BY THE
AUTHOR -- THAT THEY THEY ARE
VERY VERY VERY IN.
A VERY SMALL PORTION OF THE
DEALERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THIS IS A A A
NUCLEAR BOMB TO TRY TO AFFECT A
VERY FEW -- NUMBER OF BUSINESSES
IN FACT IT POTENTIALLY COULD PUT
ALL DEALERS OUT OF BUSINESS.
LOW'S REASONS -- WE OPPOSE
INCLUDING THE NATIONAL SHOOTING
SPORTS FOUNDATION. ONE TO MAKE
SURE YOU GOT IT MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS ADEQUATE COMMITTEE
FOR THE RECORD DâN RE WITH
NATURAL SOCIAIS TIONAL SO HERE
FOR CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION.
IN STRONG OPPOSITION ALL ECHO
WITH MY COLLEAGUE MISTER PRATHER
SAID -- I'M UNAWARE OF OF THIS
CALL THIS TYPE OF INSURANCE EVEN
EXISTING THAT -- PROTECTS
AGAINST -- ACTS OF ADDITIONAL
PEOPLE THAT ARE AGAINST THE LAW
I MEAN I WOULD BE VERY CURIOUS
TO SEE IF THAT'S AVAILABLE TODAY
AND AND SEE IF THAT COULD BE
PROVIDED.
I'M ALSO THERE'S THERE'S A
PROVISION IN THE AMENDMENT THAT
ALLOWS -- LOCAL LOCALITIES TO
IMPOSE EVEN MORE STRINGENT
REQUIREMENTS SO DOES THAT MEAN --
CITY A IS GOING TO HAVE REQUIRED
TWO MILLION PER INCIDENT OR FIVE
MILLION -- I'M.
YOU KNOW VARIOUS GUN DEALERS
HAVE DIFFERENT SIZE INVENTORIES
AND I CAN'T IMAGINE THE COSTS ON
ON THIS TYPE OF POLICY IF IT
DOES EXIST -- HI I JUST I THINK
IT'S GOING TO BE IMPOSSIBLE TO
COMPLY WITH -- ALONG WITH THE
HOST OF LOCAL ORDINANCES THAT
COULD COME WITH THAT WERE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
IMMIGRANT CRP A AND ARE A MEMBER
OR STRONGLY OPPOSED.
OKAY.
ARE ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS COMMENT.
YEAH I THINK CLEARLY THIS --
THIS PROVIDES AS THE OPPOSITION
JUST STATED.
SEVERAL UNREALISTIC MANDATES AND
I THINK THAT PUTTING GUN DEALERS
OUT OF BUSINESS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WOULD PLEASE SOME OF
THE PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM.
MAKE A MOTION TO MOVE THE BILL.
REMOVED AND SECOND -- YOU MAKE
CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK BY ABOUT.
IT SO MISS MESSAGE I THANK YOU
FOR TAKING.
THE AMENDMENTS -- THE CONCERNS
OF THE AND I PROBABLY SHOULD ASK
YOU.
IN YOUR CLOTHES ABOUT THE
MILLION DOLLAR BECAUSE THAT THAT
WAS ONE OF MY CONCERNS ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT -- ANYONE WAS
CAPABLE OF BEING ABLE -- TO GET
THAT INSURANCE WAS ONE BUT TO
WHETHER IT BE THE TYPE OF
INSURANCE.
THAT WOULD.
THAT ANY PERSON COULD GET WITH
THEIR HOUSE OR WITH ANYTHING
ELSE ON THAT THIS WOULD NOT
PRECLUDE ANYBODY.
FROM GETTING IT BUT MORE
IMPORTANT THAT IT WAS NOT -- I
THINK YOU STATED TO ME THAT IT
WAS NOT SOMETHING.
THAT YOU LOOKED AT IS PUTTING
PEOPLE OUT OF BUSINESS THE THE
MILLION DOLLARS OF WHICH IS
LIABILITY TO HANDLE.
IF SOMETHING WERE TO
UNFORTUNATELY HAPPEN TO WOULD BE
SOMETHING IN PLACE -- TO TO HELP
WITH THE DAMAGES THAT OCCURRED.
AND SO -- I'VE.
GO AHEAD IN IN INTO A LET'S MOVE
FORWARD WITH THIS BUT I WHEN HE
GETS TO THE FLOOR.
I HOPE THAT WE OR DID YOU CAN
BRING TO THE COMMITTEE IN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND ME
ESPECIALLY SHOWING THAT -- THE
MILLION DOLLAR REQUIREMENT IS
NOT COST PROHIBITIVE.
AT IN ANY WAY SHAPE OR FORM
BECAUSE THAT I THINK THAT.
AGAIN WOULD BE PROBLEMATIC --
FOR FOR ME I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
THE OTHER MEMBERS BUT IT WOULD
BE FOR ME.
CAROLINE MISTER CHAIRMAN AS AS I
INDICATED MY OPENING STATEMENT
ACCORDING TO GET FIRST LAWCENTER
THERE ARE ALREADY -- THIRTY TWO
JURISDICTIONS IN CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
LOS ANGELES THAT ALREADY HAS
THIS -- LIABILITY INSURANCE
REQUIREMENT WITH THE MINIMUM
COVERAGE OF ONE MILLION DOLLARS
SO YOU KNOW IF IF THERE IS ANY --
ANY CLARIFICATION THAT THAT THAT
THAT'S NEEDED I I WILL CERTAINLY
PROVIDE THAT TO YOU -- AND TO
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THAT THAT REQUEST THAT
OKAY SO LET'S GET CLARIFICATION
ON THAT THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU.
ON AB TEN SIXTY FOR THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
PRIVACY AND CONSUMER PROTECTION
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER. TO
ANSWER I LACKEY.
LACKEY NOPE BAUER-KAHAN.
BAUER-KAHAN I DEEP NO DEEP NO
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
QUIRK HI QUIRK I SANTIAGO.
WICKS WICKS I THE MEASURES ARE
CALL NEEDS ONE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
FOR MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
I'M SORRY MS GONZALEZ WHATEVER
YEARS.
I ANSWER TO IT ALL [inaudible]
ALL [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT -- MY TALKING POINTS
SAY GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
THAT A GOOD AFTERNOON AFTER THE
SIX YEARS AGO CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANTS GAIN THE RIGHT TO A
DRIVER'S LICENSE SO THEY COULD
BE LAW ABIDING DRIVERS AN EFFORT
AIMED AT PROVIDING ALL THIS
PEACE OF MIND.
ON THE ROAD BUT NOW FEAR IS
UNDERMINED AB SIXTY LICENSE
PROGRAM RECENT NEWS REPORTS HAVE
BEEN COVERED THAT SOMEHOW
IMMIGRATION CUSTOMS ENFORCEMENT
HAS BEEN ACCESSING STATE RUN
DATABASES CONTAINING INFORMATION
ABOUT INDIVIDUALS WITH LICENSEES.
AT THAT WERE MADE AVAILABLE
UNDER AB.
SIXTY IT'S NOT.
IT APPEARS THAT OUR EYES COULD
LEARN THE NAME OF AN IMMIGRANT
AND PUT IT INTO THE CLASS.
DATABASE AND END UP PULLING UP --
THE INFORMATION FROM THEIR THEIR
DRIVER'S LICENSE.
AS A RESULT THERE HAVE BEEN
NUMEROUS PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN --
OTHERWISE LAW ABIDING FOLKS WHO
HAVE BEEN DETAINED BY ICE
[inaudible]
THIS I WE WOULD LIKE TO AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN WOULD
PREVENT CALIFORNIA LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES FROM MAKING
THEIR DATABASES INCLUDING THOSE
MAINTAINED BY PRIVATE VENDORS
AVAILABLE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT.
THIS WOULD NOT APPLY TO
INFORMATION WITHIN THOSE
DATABASES ON INDIVIDUALS WITH
ACTIVE ARREST WARRANTS IN OTHER
WORDS THEY COULDN'T GO FISHING
THROUGH THE DATABASE TO FIND
INFORMATION ON OTHERWISE.
LAW ABIDING IMMIGRANTS DATE
COULD ONLY USE THAT IF THERE IS
AN ACTIVE ARREST WARRANT -- THE
DMV ASSERTS IT DOES NOT RELEASE
ANY APPLICANT A DOCUMENTS EXCEPT
IN RESPONSE TO CRIMINAL CURRENT
CRIMINAL SUBPOENA SO THIS WILL
CLOSE THAT LOOPHOLE -- THESE
FEDERAL IMMIGRATION POLICY
TACTICS ARE CONCERNING OBVIOUSLY
TO COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE AND
THEY'RE KEEPING PEOPLE FROM.
RE UPPING THEIR AB SIXTY LICENSE
WHICH MAKES OUR STREETS ALL AND
SEE MORE AND SAFE FOR ALL OF US.
A I HAVE.
CHIRLA HERE -- TO TEST FIND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN A MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JOSEPH JETT
ADDRESS OUR POLICY NOW BECAUSE
HE WOULD CHEER Là.
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT STRONG
SUPPORT AB SEVENTY FORTY SEVEN
IMMIGRATION INFORMANTS
ENFORCEMENT HAS A BALL FROM
HUMAN OF FOR ENFORCEMENT TO
AUTOMATED ENFORCEMENT BASE AND
IS THAT A BASIS.
WE SELL A PEAK WHEN SECURE
COMMUNITIES WAS CREATED DURING
THE BUSH ERA. TO TURN THE
FINGERPRINT OF ANYONE INTO A AND
ALSO SHARED WITH DHS WHEN THEY
DO AN INVESTIGATION.
THIS AUTOMATED SYSTEM IS A
RESULTING OR IS IT RESULTING IN
THE RUSSIAN OF TRUST BETWEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES THE AUTOMATED SYSTEM
INCLUDE INCLUDES.
THIRD PARTY ENTITIES IN WHICH
THERE IS NO ICE THE IN WHICH I
SCHEME.
IS THAT A WITH THE BILL OKAY IN
ART IS NOT REQUIRED TO PRODUCE A
JUDICIAL WARRANT.
SINCE IMPLEMENTATION OF AB SIXTY
CHIRLA HAS HER OF CASES OF THAT
WERE BROUGHT TO ATTENTION IN
WHICH WE ALSO BROUGHT TO THE
ATTENTION OF THE NBS STAFF OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAD.
NO CRIMINAL OFFENSES THE ONLY
THING THAT THE HOW DIRECTOR WES
ANY QUESTION TO PETITION ORDER --
UP AS AN EXAMPLE IS -- IS A
MEMBER THAT WE HAD.
GABRIELLE WHO WAS THE REMOVAL
PROCEEDINGS A FORMER RESIDENTS
OF WEST COVINA HE APPLIED FOR A
DRIVER LICENSE USING HIS REAL
NAME -- AND HE'S ADDRESS AND ALL
HIS CURRENT INFORMATION AFTER
SEVERAL WEEKS -- HOMELESS
SECURITY INVESTIGATION A UNIT OF
ICE SHOP TOO HE'S TO HIS HOUSE
AND ESSENTIALLY DEPORT HIM.
THIS BILL.
RISK PROTECTIONS I'M ALREADY
UNDER AB SIXTY WITHOUT ANY
DIFFERENT WE LAW ENFORCEMENT OR
ANY OTHER DATABASES FOR ALL
THOSE REASONS WE AS WE TAKE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN FRENCH THIS IN
THIS BILL AND WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MARGOT GEORGE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
KATHY SURE FOR THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANYWAY THIS IS IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
YOU MAKE LOOKS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAY VOTE
[inaudible]
SECOND.
ON AB SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN THE
MOTION IS DEPOSITED JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER TO ANSWER
I LACKEY.
LACKEY NOT VOTING BAUER-KAHAN.
DEEP A ROAD DEEP NOT VOTING
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
QUIRK [inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
WICKS WICKS I THAT.
MEASURES ON CALL WE NEED THREE
MORE.
WE NEED TO MORE BODIES
[inaudible]
SO.
UNLESS MR LACKEY WOULD LIKE TO
GO NOW [inaudible]
OKAY
[inaudible]
YOU [inaudible]
YOU NEED.
THE BILL ALL [inaudible]
OKAY
--
YES DO IT.
START WITH WHICH ONE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO STOP START WITH.
YES MISTER THE OPERAS HERE SO
THAT'S GREAT.
THEY CAN CARE.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY A. B. SIXTEEN
THIRTY SIX CRIMINAL PROCEDURE
DETERMINATION OF PROBABLE CAUSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES IN THANK YOU STAFF
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
AB.
SIXTEEN THIRTY SIX THE PURPOSE
OF WHICH IS TO REDUCE
PROSECUTORIAL OVERCHARGING.
IN CRIMINAL COURTS INTO APPLIED
OF FELONIES PROTECTIONS THAT
ALREADY EXISTS UNDER CURRENT LAW.
FOR MISDEMEANORS AB SIXTEEN
THIRTY SIX ALLOWS A PERSON
IMMEDIATELY AT THE INITIAL.
ARRAIGNMENT TO TO REQUEST A
DETERMINATION OF PROBABLE CAUSE
ON EACH CHARGE THE JUDGE WILL
THEN MAKE THE DETERMINATION
BEFORE THE CASE.
CONTINUES WHY IS THIS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE WITH OVER CHARGING
CHARGING. FOR CRIMES FOR WHICH
THERE IS NOT YET PROBABLE CAUSE
OR MAY NEVER BE.
IT CAN LEAD TO UNNECESSARY
DEPRIVATION OF LIBERTY. FOR
INDIVIDUALS IT CAN ALSO LEAD TO
WRONGFUL CONVICTIONS AS INNOCENT.
PEOPLE ARE FORCED INTO ACCEPTING
PLEA DEALS IN LIEU OF SERIOUS
CHARGES THAT MAY NOT BE BASED ON
PROBABLE CAUSE.
WITH.
THE CHARGES INTERACTION WITH
BAIL [inaudible]
THE CHARGE COOLEY TO CRITICALLY
HIGH BAIL SCHEDULES OR HI BILL
AMOUNTS -- WHICH DETAIN FOLKS
AND HAVE PUT AT RISK THEIR JOBS
THERE -- KIDS POTENTIALLY THEIR
HOMES THEIR CARS AND FURTHER
ENCOURAGE THEM AND SENT THEM TO
TAKE CONVICTIONS THAT THAT THEY
ARE TO TAKE PLEASE THAT MAY NOT
BE APPROPRIATE -- THEY ALSO WHEN
YOU'RE DETAINED IT IT'S HARDER
TO MAKE YOUR CASE AND TO BE OUT
AND IN THE COMMUNITY WITH YOUR
ATTORNEY AND BE ABLE TO DEFEND
YOURSELF -- AND WE ALSO KNOW
FROM DATA INCLUDING DATA FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF PENNSYLVANIA.
THAT WITH OUR OVER CHARGING
THEIR DESPERATE OUTCOMES SHARPLY
DIVIDED ALONG
RACIAL LINES
AND I
CAN TELL YOU FROM HAVING
PRACTICED IN TWO COUNTIES CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY.
AND SEPARATE CISCO DID DOES
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT PEOPLE
DEPENDING ON WHAT SIDE OF THE
TRACKS YOU LIVE ON
DISPROPORTIONATELY SOME CARRYING
IN PRISON IF [inaudible]
DOES PSYCHOLOGICALLY TRAUMATIZED
THE PERSON HEARING THOSE CHARGES.
TO THE CLASSICAL COLLATERAL
CONSEQUENCES OF PROLONGED
INCARCERATION EVEN IF THE
PRESENT IS DONE AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE WHICH IS TWO WEEKS.
IN THAT TIME SUMMIT COULD LOSE
THEIR JOB.
CBS CAN BECOME INVOLVED.
HOUSING CAN BE LOST BECAUSE THE
BAIL IS LINKED TO THE CHARGES.
AND IT'S NOT ALWAYS EASY TO DO
THAT PRELIMINARY HEARING TWO
WEEKS BECAUSE THERE HAS TO BE
TIME TO PREPARE.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY FOLKS WHO
FEEL THEY ARE NOT GUILTY ACROSS
THE STATE ARE PLEADING GUILTY
DAY IN AND DAY OUT.
AND THEY'RE DOING THAT BECAUSE
THEY FEAR CRUSHING SENTENCES AND
THEY FEAR MULTIPLE SERIOUS
CONVICTIONS. TOO MANY.
ARE AFRAID. TO EXERCISE THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO A TRIAL
THEIR OPPORTUNITY TO SHOW THEIR
INNOCENCE BECAUSE THE RISK IS
SIMPLY. TOO HIGH [inaudible]
IT'S UNFAIR.
IT'S MORE THE WRONG.
IT'S A PERVERSION OF THE
FUNDAMENTAL PILLARS.
OF OUR SYSTEM THAT A PRESUMPTION
OF INNOCENCE AND PROVE BEYOND A
REASONABLE DOUBT.
THIS LEGISLATION FURTHER WOULD
BE A DETERRENT TO OVER CHARGING
TO BEGIN WITH AND IT DOES
PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CORRECT THAT.
WHEN IT HAPPENS WITHOUT DELAY
WHEN APPROPRIATE?
CALIFORNIA OFTEN LEADS THE
NATION IN CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM.
I COURAGE US TO KEEP IT GOING.
IN ORDER IN HONOR OF JEFF LET'S
PASS THIS LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT. TWO MINUTES A YES SIR.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ESPANA IS
ON THE POLICY COORDINATOR FOR
THE ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION.
I'M ALSO KNOWN AS A R. C..
A. R. C. IS A SUPPORT NETWORK
FOREIGN COMPRISE A FORMALLY
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS ALL
DEVOTED TO BECOMING -- LEADERS
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
AIR SEE ACCOMPLISHES ITS GOALS
BY PROVIDING JOB TRAINING.
SUPPORT OF HOUSING COMPREHENSIVE
KATE CASE MANAGEMENT.
AND BY CONNECTED ITS MEMBERS TO
EMPLOYMENT AND EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES.
PART TWO ENGAGING IN THESE
OPPORTUNITIES MANY AIR SEA
MEMBERS SERVED LONG PRISON
SENTENCES FOR OFFENSES COMMITTED
DURING THEIR YOUTH.
FROM FEAR OF BEING CONVICTED OF
MORE THAN THEY WERE GUILTY OF
SOME OF THESE MEMBERS TOOK PLEA
BARGAINS.
WHEN I FIRST HEARD ABOUT THIS
BILL I THOUGHT ABOUT?
THOSE OF MY MENTEES THAT TOOK
PLEA BARGAINS.
BUT SINCE I ONLY HAVE TWO
MINUTESI WILL TELL YOU ABOUT
ONE OF THEM [inaudible]
ANTONIO WELLINGTON.
ANTONIO IS A HOT SHOT FOR THE US
FORESTRY SERVICE.
BUT BEFORE HE BECAME A HOT SHOT
HE WAS CHARGED WITH FIVE ARMED
ROBBERIES.
FACING NEARLY TWO DECADES IN AN
ADULT PRISON.
ANTONIO CHOSE TO TAKE THE FIRST
PLEA BARGAIN HE WAS GIVEN. ONE
COUNT OF ARMED ROBBERY WHEN HE
WAS REALLY ONLY GUILTY OF
BURGLARY.
HE TOOK THIS PLEA BECAUSE AND I
QUOTE.
IT DIDN'T MATTER IF I ACTUALLY
DID IT OR NOT.
THEY WANTED ME TO BE GUILTY.
STE AND I DIDN'T WANT TO GAMBLE
WITH MY LIFE [inaudible]
FEAR [inaudible]
TREPIDATION [inaudible]
DESPERATION.
AND NOT BEING ABLE TO POST BAIL.
ALL BROUGHT THIS SIXTEEN YEAR
OLD TEENAGER. TO PLEASE TO AN
ADULT FELONY.
ANTONIO STORY EXEMPLIFIES HOW
OVER CHARGING CAN LEAD.
EVEN OUR YOUTH INTO PLAIN GUILTY
TO CRIMES THEY DIDN'T COMMIT.
THIS FEAR OF BEING CONVICTED OF
THESE OVER CHARGING OR FAR
REACHING CHARGES LET ANTONIO TO
TAKE A PLEA BARGAIN BEFORE HE
EVEN WENT INTO IS A AND TO HIS
PRELIMINARY HEARINGS.
AND I USE THE TERM FAR REACHING
BECAUSE ALL WE ARE ASKING.
IS FOR AN OPPORTUNITY TO ALLOW
DEFENDANTS. TO ASK THE JUDGE FOR
HIS OR HER DISCRETION ON WHETHER
PROBABLE CAUSE EXISTS WITHIN THE
CHARGES.
IF THE JUDGE THEN DEEMS THE
PROBABLE CAUSE DOES IN FACT
EXIST.
THEN IT'S BUSINESS AS USUAL.
AS I WAS AS I'M SURE THIS
COMMITTEE KNOWS IT IS NOT HARD
TO PROVE PROBABLE CAUSE.
BEING A FIREFIGHTER HAS BECOME A
DREAM OF ANTONIO'S.
YEAH BECAUSE OF THIS ADULT PHONY
THAT HE PLAYED TO HIS HIS UNABLE
TO OBTAIN AN EMT LICENSE.
ANTONIO IS JUST ONE OF MANY
EXAMPLES OF INDIVIDUALS THAT
HAVE FACED THE I'M JUST
PRESSURES OF OVERCHARGING.
THIS BILL PROPERLY GIVES JUDGES
DISCRETION TO APPLY CHARGES WITH
MORE FAIRNESS AND MORE REASONING.
I THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR TIME
AND I STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT
ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MARGOT GEORGE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
JOCKEY WILSON SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE STRONG
SUPPORT.
MARCIN MAZA SENSIBLE DEFENDER'S
OFFICE I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
YOLANDA LE DOES MY WAS SILICON
VALLEY DEBUG IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
BUT NAY THE HARDWOOD SILICON
VALLEY DEBUG BURN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
LAURIE VALDEZ WITH SILICON
VALLEY DEBUG AND WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
JOSEPH IT TEARS WITH SILICON
VALLEY DEBUG AND STRONG SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
SUSAN WILL OF SILICON VALLEY
DEBUG STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
APRIL VANDYKE DEPUTY PUBLIC
DEFENDER IN SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
STRONGLY SUPPORTING.
DENISE PRAYER DEPUTY PUBLIC
DEFENDER SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION.
ALEXA HORNER WITH THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
I'M RADIO FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
KATHY SURE FOR THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
SURE AND MARK IS SILICON VALLEY
DEBUG STRONG SUPPORT.
DONNA MANDEL SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
MANY HAD CALIFORNIA CIVIL
LIBERTIES ADVOCACY AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WHEN WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
YES SIR
.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS LAURIE MORE SOMEBODY
HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION.
WE ARE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA IS AB.
SIXTEEN THIRTY SIX THIS BILL
CREATES AN ENTIRELY NEW.
COSTLY AND UNNECESSARY LAYER OF
CRIMINAL PROCEDURE IN ORDER TO
ESTABLISH THE PROBABLE CAUSE
EXISTS IN A FELONY COMPLAINT.
UNDER CURRENT LAW ALL PERSONS
ARRESTED FOR A FELONY OFFENSE
HAVE A RIGHT TO A CONTESTED
PROBABLE CAUSE HEARING I EAT A
PRELIMINARY HEARING WITHIN TEN
DAYS OF THEIR ARRAIGNMENT.
THIS TIME HONORED PROCEDURE.
THAT A MAGISTRATE DETERMINES
AFTER AN EVIDENTIARY HEARING IN
WHICH WITNESSES ON BOTH SIDES
CAN BE CALLED THAT THERE IS
SUFFICIENT EVIDENCE FOR A
DEFENDANT TO FACE TRIAL ON THE
CHARGES.
IF A MAGISTRATE DETERMINES THAT
THE EVIDENCE IS INSUFFICIENT.
ANY OR ALL OF THE CHARGES ARE
DISMISSED.
AB SIXTEEN THIRTY SIX WHAT
ESSENTIALLY CREATE AN ADDITIONAL
PROBABLE CAUSE HEARING AT
ARRAIGNMENT.
THIS WILL DRAMATICALLY SNARL THE
COURT SYSTEM BY REQUIRING HIGH
VOLUME ARRAIGNMENT JUDGES TO
REVIEW DECLARATIONS POLICE
REPORTS OR OTHER RECORDS TO
JUSTIFY THE CHARGES IN THE
COMPLAINT.
AND UNLIKE A PRELIMINARY HEARING
IN WHICH WITNESSES ARE CALLED AB
SIXTEEN THIRTY SIX CALL FOR A
SIMPLE PAPER REVIEW.
WITH NO WITNESS TESTIMONY BEING
TAKEN.
MOREOVER THE FINDINGS OF THE
ARRAIGNMENT MAGISTRATE AREN'T
EVEN BINDING ON THE MAGISTRATE
AT THE SUBSEQUENT PRELIMINARY
HEARING.
AS A COURTROOM PROSECUTOR FOR
TWENTY SIX YEARS I CAN TELL YOU
THAT AB SIXTEEN THIRTY SIX IS ON
WORKABLE.
IN MANY SERIOUS CASES THAT
INVOLVE ELECTRONIC RECORDS FOR
EXAMPLE CHARGES ARE OFTEN ADDED
ONCE THOSE ELECTRONIC RECORDS
ARE REVIEWED IF THE DEFENDANT
WERE ENTITLED TO AN IMMEDIATE
HEARING WITHIN SEVENTY TWO HOURS
IS THIS BILL PROPOSES.
COURTS WOULD BE FORCED TO REVIEW
VOLUMINOUS RAW RECORDS OR
EVIDENCE BECAUSE THEY HEARING IS
TAKING PLACE FASTER THAN THE
POLICE REPORTS CAN BE COMPILED.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY PROBLEMATIC
IN HUMAN TRAFFICKING PROSECUTION
FOR EXAMPLE THIS BILL WILL
COMPLICATE HUMAN TRAFFICKING
PROSECUTIONS AND LIKELY RESULT
IN DISMISSAL OR DELAY OF
LEGITIMATE HUMAN TRAFFICKING
CHARGES.
THERE BY PUTTING MORE VICTIMS AT
RISK.
OFTENTIMES ARRESTS ARE MADE BUT
IF IN ADDITIONAL INVESTIGATION
CONTINUES AND POLICE OFFICERS
NEED TIME TO WRITE REPORTS OR
COLLECT EVIDENCE.
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY MAKES A
DETERMINATION OF THE APPROPRIATE
CHARGES TO FILE OFTEN WITH MORE
INFORMATION THAN THE INITIAL
RATHER ARRESTING OFFICER HAD AT
THE TIME OF THE ARREST.
HAVING TEN COURT DAYS TO
COMPLETE FURTHER INVESTIGATION
AND COMPILE INVESTIGATIVE
REPORTS INSURERS THAT AT THE
TIME THE MAGISTRATE IS CALLED
UPON. TO MAKE A PROBABLE CAUSE
DETERMINATION HE OR SHE HAS ALL
AVAILABLE INFORMATION.
WHILE THE PROCEDURE SIMILAR TO
A. B. SIXTEEN THIRTY SIX
EXISTING MISDEMEANOR COURT VIA
PENAL CODE SECTION.
NINE NINE ONE IT IS FRANKLY
ALMOST NEVER USED.
AND THERE ARE PIVOTAL
DISTINCTIONS FIRST MISDEMEANOR
CASES DO NOT HAVE THE PROTECTION
OF A PRELIMINARY EXAMINATION
WITHIN TEN COURT DAYS OF RAIN.
SECOND.
PC NINE NINE ONE ONLY APPLIES TO
MISDEMEANORS WHO ARE IN CUSTODY
THIS BILL WOULD APPLY TO ALL
FELONIES REGARDLESS OF CUSTODIAL
STATUS.
ESPECIALLY ALARMING IS THE
RECENT AMENDMENT TO THIS BILL
WHICH WOULD CREATE A DISMISSAL
WITH PREJUDICE.
AGAIN THIS WILL DRAMATICALLY
IMPACT HUMAN TRAFFICKING IN
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CASES FOR
EXAMPLE IN WHICH THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGE TO A SUCCESSFUL
PROSECUTION IS GAINING THE
COOPERATION OF WITNESSES.
CASES ARE OFTEN DISMISSED
BECAUSE OF VICTIMS FAILED TO
SHOW UP THIS BILL WOULD RESTRICT
OUR ABILITY TO REFILE CASES WHEN.
TO VICTIMS DECIDE TO COOPERATE.
FINALLY THIS BILL REQUIRES THE
MAGISTRATE TO CONSIDER ANY OF
EVIDENCE PROFFERED BY THE
DEFENDANT THAT SUPPORTS A
FINDING OF NO PROBABLE CAUSE.
BY CONFERRING A RIGHT TO PRESENT
EVIDENCE.
THIS PROVISION WILL ALLOW THE
DEFENSE TO PRESENT UNTESTED AND
UNCONTRADICTED EVIDENCE AT A
HEARING.
DESIGNED TO ESTABLISH PROBABLE
CAUSE.
IN SOME THIS BILL IS UNNECESSARY
DUPLICATIVE OF OTHER LONG
ESTABLISHED SAFEGUARDS AND WOULD
CAUSE AN EXPENSIVE AN
UNREASONABLE BURDEN ON THE
JUDICIAL SYSTEM. FOR THESE
REASONS CDA IS VIGOROUSLY
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL THANK.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS CORY CELLS --
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION.
HE TOOK ALL MY ARGUMENTS SO FOR
THE IN IN THE INTEREST OF TIME
IN THE COMMITTEES RESOURCES I'LL
SIMPLY SAY WOULD ASSOCIATE OUR
MARKS WITH MISTER MORRISON --
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU KNOW VOTE
THANK YOU I WAS WORRIED ABOUT
THAT.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ARE YOU QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
YES MISS PARK AREA [inaudible]
I'M.
SO.
THE RATE TO A PROBABLE CAUSE
HEARING WE INCARCERATE SOMEONE
TO TAKE THEIR FREEDOM AWAY
BEFORE WE HOLD THEM IS OBVIOUSLY
A RIGHT THAT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
SHOULD NEVER TOUCH -- AND THAT
RIGHT STANDS I GUESS I'M
STRUGGLING WITH WHY WE NEED TO
APPLY THIS TO ALL THE CHARGES
WHAT IS THE BENEFIT OF THAT AND
SECONDARILY.
I'M CONCERNED WITH THE ABILITY
TO ADD ON AND IS THERE ANYTHING
THAT WOULD STOP A PROSECUTOR
FROM LATER ADDING ON CHARGES.
AND IF THEY WERE TO DISCOVER
AGAIN IN THE PILE OF EVIDENCE
THAT THERE WERE OTHER CHARGES
THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN BROUGHT
THAT WERE NOT.
REALIZED IN THOSE FIRST THREE
DAYS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION.
MY VIEW IS THAT IF IF YOU HAVE
THIS FOR MISDEMEANORS FOR LOWER
LEVELS OF CRIME.
WHEN THE STAKES ARE ARGUABLY
LOWER?
THAT YOU SHOULD HAVE THEM FOR
FELONIES WHEN THE STAKES ARE
MUCH HIGHER WHERE YOU CAN BE
DEPRIVED OF YOUR LIBERTY WHERE
YOU COULD BE.
PRESSURED TO TAKE A PLEA
[inaudible]
AND ALTHOUGH A A FULL
EVIDENTIARY HEARING IS TEN DAYS
AWAY FROM THE ARRAIGNMENT AT THE
PROBABLE -- AT THE PRELIMINARY
HEARING.
THAT COULD BE A LIFETIME.
WHEN YOU'RE IN JAIL AWAY FROM
YOUR JOB AWAY FROM YOUR KIDS?
THINKING ABOUT YOUR FUTURE
THINKING ABOUT WHETHER YOU
SHOULD TAKE A PLEA.
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT WE
SHOULD TAKE LIGHTLY [inaudible]
AND I AM [inaudible]
SO.
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT WE HAVE THIS OPPORTUNITY.
I AM.
AT EARLY STAGE BECAUSE THIS BILL
BASICALLY SAYS THIS.
CHARGE WE HAVE THE EVIDENCE.
FOR CHARTER YOU HAVE PROBABLE
CAUSE.
FOR IF YOU DON'T HAVE PROBABLE
CAUSE TODAY BUT YOU THINK YOU
MIGHT LATER.
WAIT.
AND THEN YOU CAN CHARGE WHEN
WHEN THE PROBABLE CAUSES
REALIZED BUT DON'T OVER CHARGE
BECAUSE YOU WANT TO BE IN A
POSITION OF LEVERAGE.
AND BETTER NEGOTIATING POWER AND
HAVE A DEFENDANT OVER THE
BARRELS THAT YOU CAN HAVE THEM
TAKE A PLEA.
ON SOMETHING TO GET YOUR CASE
LOW DOWN.
THAT'S NOT FAIR THAT'S NOT RIGHT
WE KNOW OVER CHARGING IS A
PROBLEM.
THIS IS A MODEST PROPOSAL TO ASK
A JUDGE IT WILL BE A NEUTRAL
ARBITER.
WHO WILL SEE EVIDENCE AND WILL
DETERMINE WHETHER AT THAT MOMENT
THERE'S PROBABLE CAUSE FOR THE
CURRENT CHARGES -- AND IT WILL
INCENT PROSECUTORS TO CHARGE
WHAT THEY HAVE EVIDENCE FOR AND
NOT TO CHARGE WHAT THEY DON'T
HAVE EVIDENCE FOR BUT TO YOUR
QUESTION THEY WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CHARGE AT A LATER
TIME BUT THEY HAVE.
PROBABLE CAUSE FOR AS THEIR
INVESTIGATION CONTINUES.
ANY OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS WERE
QUESTIONS.
A MISTER BONTA.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU AYE AYE.
RIGHT DID YOU.
DID YOU ONCE I'M SORRY YOU LEVEL
OKAY.
ARE YOU LOOK AT ME LIKE YOU WANT
TO TRY IT IS OR I DON'T WANT TO
OKAY RESPONDED BY ANNOUNCED
QUEST OKAY.
GO IT MISSED BEHIND.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY I
YOU KNOW I I JUST WANT TO ECHO
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WERE
SAID EARLIER ABOUT.
A PUBLIC DEFENDER ADACHI.%
I REMEMBER THE TIME HE CALLED ME
AND HE ASKED ME ABOUT.
THIS IDEA THAT HE HAD. TO CREATE
SOME PARITY BETWEEN FELONIES
MISDEMEANORS WITH RESPECT TO
NINE AND ONE HEARINGS THAT HE
THOUGHT THAT IT WOULD REALLY.
HELP CURB SOMETHING THAT WE ALL
KNOW TO BE TRUE THAT THERE IS.
UNFORTUNATE OVERCHARGING IN OUR
SYSTEM.
AND I THINK THAT THIS BILL WILL
HELP CREATE AN INCENTIVE FOR
FAIR CHARGING IN CHARGE
CONSISTENT WITH EVIDENCE AND
AVOID SOME OF THE PROBLEMS THAT
WE SEEN FROM OVER CHARGES SO I
THINK IT'S A WISE AND PRUDENT
APPROACH. TO THE ONGOING
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM THAT
WE'VE BEEN PURSUING HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK PRIVATE.
THANK YOU -- CHAIRS RECOMMENDING
AND I'D ONCE I GET A MOTION
[inaudible]
OKAY.
ON AB SEARCH SIXTEEN THIRTY SIX
THE MISSION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER CHEN SIR I LACKEY.
LACKEY NO BARRICADE HAND.
BAUER-KAHAN I DEEP.
OF VOTING DEEP NOT VOTING
KAMLAGER-DOVE HAVE QUIRK
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
WICKS AN HONOR MISTER DODGY AYE
WICKS I THAT.
MEASURES ARE CALLING NEEDS.
TO THE NEXT ONE MR BONTA.
THANK YOU AB.
SIXTEEN SIXTY NINE YES MISTER
CHAIRMAN COLLEAGUES.
GUN SHOWS IN ADVANCE YES KEPT IN
ARE A BUSY TODAY.
PROPOSITION SIXTY THREE DOES NOT
REQUIRE INDEPENDENT AMMUNITION
VENDORS TO COMPLY WITH THE SAME
REQUIREMENTS AS OTHER VENDORS A.
B. SIXTEEN SIXTY NINE CLOSES THE
SECURITY LOOPHOLE INSURERS THAT
INDEPENDENT AMMUNITION VENDORS
ARE SUBJECT TO THE SAME.
VETTING REQUIREMENTS AS OTHER
VENDORS IN DOING SO A. B.
SIXTEEN SIXTY NINE STANDARDIZES
THE WAY IN WHICH FIRE ARM
DEALERS AND INDEPENDENT
AMMUNITION VENDORS.
ARE TREATED ADDITIONALLY THIS
BILL MODERNIZE THOSE.
SECOND.
THANK YOU MODERNIZE IS THE DROSS
BEAT THE THIRTY TWO DOLLARS IN
NINETEEN CENTS -- CATCHING IT UP
WITH INFLATION HAS BEEN RAISED
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND FOUR AND
BY ADJUSTING THE TRANSACTION FEE
TO MORE ACCURATELY RECOUP THE
ENFORCEMENT COST OF THE PROGRAM
THE PUBLIC CAN HAVE GREATER
SURETY THAT ALL.
AMMUNITION VENDORS ARE COMPLYING
WITH CALIFORNIA'S LAWS AB
SIXTEEN SIXTY NINE IS A COMMON
SENSE SOLUTION I RESPECTFULLY.
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE I HAVE
WITH ME HERE TODAY ACTUALLY AIRS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE.
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
SPONSOR OF AB SIXTEEN SIXTY NINE
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL HAVE YET TO
BE SET ASIDE A ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AT I GET AFTERNOON TOO MANY MY
NAME IS ACTUALLY AREAS IN THE
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE --
INSPECTED WE ARE THE SPONSORS OF
AB.
SIXTEEN SIXTY NINE AT THE BILL
ACCOMPLISHES TWO THINGS OF THE
SOME A MEMBER REFERRED TO I WILL
KEEP THIS SHORT IN LIGHT OF THE
FACT THAT WE ARE LAST BUT NOT
LEAST.
AT THE FIRST HAS BEEN IN
RELATIONSHIP TO INDEPENDENT
AMMUNITION VENDORS THE RAV THANK
YOU FOR ALL ACT PROP SIXTY THREE
ADDRESSED.
I MEAN SOME ANY MINUTE
AMMUNITION VENDORS BUT DID NOT
ADDRESS ALL OF THE PENAL CODE
SECTIONS OF THOSE VENDORS WHO
MAY BE SELLING AMMUNITION IT
WOULD INCORPORATE.
THE ELEMENTS OF PROP SIXTY THREE
TO ALL OF THE PENAL CODE SECTION
SO THAT DEALERS ARE TREATED.
EQUALLY AND THERE IS NO
DIFFERENT IMPACT AND DEPENDING
ON WHAT IS IT YOU ARE SELLING
AND WHERE.
THE SECOND PORTION OF THE BILL
RELATES TO THE DEALER RECORD OF
SALE OR THE GROSS FEES -- WE ARE
PROPOSING TO RAISE THE FEE TO
THIRTY TWO DOLLARS IN NINETEEN
CENTS.
IN ADDITION -- TO READING IT.
INDEPENDENT OF THE CPI AND
GRANTING THE DEPARTMENT ALREADY
IN ORDER TO ADJUST AS NECESSARY.
A COUPLE OF THINGS I WILL SAY IN
REGARDS TO THIS THE NUMBER IT
THAT WAS CALCULATED WITH A VERY
SPECIFIC CALCULATION AND VERY
PRECISE CALCULATION.
IT IS INTENDED TO COVER THE COST
OF ALL OF THE LEGISLATION THAT
HAS BEEN PASSED UP UNTIL THIS
POINT IN ORDER SO THAT THE
DROVES.
ACCOUNT DOES NOT OPERATE IN THE
NEGATIVE SO IT IS NOT
PERSPECTIVE IT ALL IS NOT
INTENDED TO COVER ANY FUTURE
LEGISLATION WITHOUT THIS FEE
INCREASE THE ACCOUNT WILL BE
NEGATIVE OVER A PERIOD OF TIME.
ADDITIONALLY I HAVE.
IN REGARDS TO THE CPI EVEN IF
THE DEPARTMENT HAD RAISED THE
CPI FOR THE LAST TIME THE CPI.
WITH THAT HE WAS RATES BY CP I
WAS IN TWO THOUSAND FOUR SO EVEN
IF THE DEPARTMENT HAD RAISED BY
THE CBI EVERY YEAR SINCE TWO
THOUSAND FOR THE ULTIMATE FEE
WOULD NOT COVER THE ULTIMATE
COST.
OF ALL THE PROGRAMMATIC NEEDS AT
THE DEPARTMENT RELIES ON THE
SPECIAL FUNDS FOR THE DEALER
RECORD OF SALE IT WOULD NOT BE
ENOUGH.
SO THANK YOU AGAIN I HAVE WITH
ME IF THE COMMITTEE HAS ANY
QUESTIONS IN REGARDS TO THE
INDEPENDENT MISSION IN A LICENSE
OR ANY OTHER TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
OUR SPECIAL AGENT IN CHARGE
BILLY GRAHAM WITH THE
DEPARTMENT'S BUREAU FIREARMS.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
YES.
AMANDA WILCOX HERE ON BEHALF OF
BRADY CALIFORNIA WERE IN SUPPORT
OF THE PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL
THAT ADDRESS THE EMISSION VENDER
UM LICENSE SITUATION AT GUN
SHOWS A MAKE A COMPLIANCE WITH
THE PROVISIONS OF PROP.
SIXTY THREE AND WE DO INDEED
SUPPORT RAISING THE TROPHY I'VE
ACTUALLY ADVOCATED THAT -- FOR
NUMBER OF YEARS NOW -- I
UNDERSTAND THE PREDICAMENT THAT
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
JUSTICES IN IN TERMS OF TRYING
TO FIND THE ALL THE REQUIREMENTS
THAT HAVE BEEN IMPOSED ON THEM.
AND THE DROSE FEE HAS BEEN REYES
ONCE SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE OUR SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE THE COST OF
GUNS HAVE GONE UP THE COST OF
LABOR HAS GONE UP AND WE HAVE
NOW ACTED.
LAWS THAT HAVE PLACE DEMAND ON
THE DRUGS HE ACCOUNT ONE OF
WHICH WAS THE DISARM HATE ACT --
THAT WAS CARRIED BY THE CHAIR
HERE.
I KNOW A BILL WITH BROAD SUPPORT
THE ANYTIME WE DO SOMETHING LIKE
THAT THERE'S A COST TO DO J. TO
CHANGE THEIR DATABASES TO
IMPLEMENT THAT LAW.
I THINK EVERYONE KNOWS THAT
THERE ARE SERIOUS ISSUES WITH
THE I. T. AND THE TECHNOLOGY
CAPABILITIES AND THE CAPACITY
ARE THAT THE DOJ SYSTEM HAS AND
THAT NEEDS TO THE X.
CONSIDERABLE INVESTMENT.
IN UPGRADE -- IF THE GROSS V.
HAD BEEN RAISED ALONG WITH THE
CONSUMER PRICE INDEX MY AT BY MY
ESTIMATE BE TWENTY SIX DOLLARS
NOW AND THAT'S OUR UNFORTUNATELY
IT ON THE FEE WAS NOT REYES
INCREMENTALLY.
WHICH WAS ALLOWED UNDER EXISTING
LAW SO NOW THEY'RE TO APPEARS TO
BE A DRASTIC INCREASE -- IT IT
FEELS DRASTIC HI I WOULD GRANT
THAT BUT IT'S BECAUSE IT WASN'T
DONE ALL ALONG AS IT SHOULD HAVE
BEEN -- THE NEED IS THERE AND
THE BRADY CALIFORNIA SUPPORTS --
RAISING THE FEE.
TO ASSESS DOJ IN DOING THE WORK
THEY'RE REQUIRED TO DO TO
IMPLEMENT OUR LOSS THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT.
A WITNESS IN OPPOSITION.
HOW AND I SHOULD TO OFFER THE
BAY AREA OF? FOR STUDENT
ACTIVISTS AREN'T SUPPORT.
NOW YOU'RE AFTER MAKE ROOM
[inaudible]
THANK.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE IT'S IT'S FIREARMS
TAX DAY APPARENTLY -- THE END
RESULT IS THE NATIONAL.
THEY AGREE WITH THE NATIONAL
RIFLE ASSOCIATION ALSO HERE FOR
C. R. PA IN STRONG OPPOSITION.
TO AB -- SIXTEEN SIXTY NINE AS
FAR AS THE CHANGES TO A
CONFORMING GUN SHOWS FOR
AMMUNITION PURCHASES WE FEEL
THAT'S COMPLETELY UNNECESSARY --
STATE AND FEDERAL LAW APPLY
WHETHER YOU'RE AT A GUN SHOW OR
AT A BRICK AND MORTAR AND SO WE
FEEL THAT THAT PORTION OF THE
BILL'S UNNECESSARY -- WITH THE
AMENDMENTS TO AB SIXTEEN SIXTY
NINE RECALL REGARDING -- DEROSE.
THERE'S A LOT TO UNPACK WHEN IT
COMES TO DROGO'S.
AND I KNOW IT'S BEEN A VERY LONG
DAY AND SOLD.
DO MY BEST TO BE BRIEF.
SO IF YOU YOU HEARD THAT THEY'RE
LOOKING TO RECOVER THE JOKES
COSTS IN AND COVER PAYMENTS I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE ORIGINAL INTENT OF THE
DRUGS HE WAS AND I WAS TO COVER.
BACKGROUND CHECKS AND THE
TRANSFER REGISTRY -- OVER THE
YEARS ESPECIALLY OVER THE LAST
TWENTY YEARS WE'VE SEEN THIS
DROVE THE GET OPENED UP TO ALL
DIFFERENT KINDS OF X. X.
EXPENDITURES TO PAY FOR ALL
DIFFERENT TYPES OF DOJ
ACTIVITIES.
AND SO I'D BE CURIOUS. TO SEE --
WHAT IS EACH PROGRAM WITHIN --
THE DROSS IS CURRENTLY PAYING --
FOR COSTING.
YOU KNOW WE WE KNOW THAT DE
DEROSE ACCOUNT HAS AMASSED A
SURPLUS IN THE TENS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS BECAUSE WE BORROWED
FROM THE DRUGS ACCOUNT TO TRY IN.
A REDUCE THE APP'S BACKLOG WHICH
IS A CONVERSATION FOR ANOTHER
DAY -- BUT WE WE SAW THAT
ACCOUNT HIT RECORD HIGHS AND NOW
FOR THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS WE'VE
HEARD THAT THE DRUGS ACCOUNTED
STRUCTURALLY IMBALANCE.
AND WE KNOW THAT THERE'S A LOT
OF STRANGE PUT BEING PUT ON THE
OJ -- BUT RIGHT NOW WE KNOW THAT.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE THE HISTORY
OF FIREARMS SALES ESPECIALLY
OVER THE LAST. SEVEN YEARS HERE
IN CALIFORNIA.
AND IN THE PERIOD WHEN WE HAD
THAT SURPLUS THERE WAS TWENTY
THIRTY FORTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
ADDRESS ACCOUNT.
THE GUN SALES ARE NOT NEARLY AS
HIGH AS THEY ARE NOW FOR THE
LAST. SEVEN YEARS WE SOLD AT
LEAST EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND
FIREARMS PER YEAR IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA -- WHICH IS ALMOST
DOUBLE WHAT WE WERE SELLING JUST
A FEW YEARS SHORT YEARS AGO WHEN
WE WERE HAVING.
THE SURPLUS I ALSO THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT NOTE THAT -- BACK IN
TWO THOUSAND TEN THERE WAS A
PROPOSED RULE FOR THE DATE
ACTUALLY REDUCE THE DRAWS COSTS --
TO BETTER REFLECT -- THEIR
ACTUAL COSTS I'M THE RULE NEVER
WENT THROUGH BUT THEY WERE
LOOKING AT TAKING IT FROM
NINETEEN DOLLARS BACK DOWN TO I
BELIEVE FIFTEEN OR FOURTEEN
DOLLARS -- BECAUSE HE SAID EVEN
THOUGH THEY'RE PROCESSING MORE
TRANSACTIONS THEIR SYSTEMS ARE
IMPROVED OBVIOUSLY AS WE'VE
ENTERED IN THE DIGITAL AGE A LOT
OF THIS IS.
IS GETTING QUICKER -- MORE
AUTOMATED I'M IN SO.
WE'RE WE'RE STRONG OPPOSITION
THIS IS JUST ANOTHER TAX ON GUN
OWNERS TO TO FOOT THE BILL --
FOR ALL THESE PROGRAMS DEROSE IS
NEVER BEEN SUBJECT TO AN AUDIT
THERE'S BEEN SEVERAL REQUEST OF
THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE TO HAVE AN AUDIT THE
DRAWS PROGRAM.
AND I THINK THAT BEFORE WE
SHOULD EVEN CONSIDER DOUBLING
THE JUROS FEE.
THERE NEEDS TO BE A SERIOUS
INQUIRY INTO WHERE THOSE MONIES
ARE GOING.
THERE IS THERE'S A LOT OF MONEY
GOING INTO THAT ACCOUNT HOW MUCH
IS GOING HOW MUCH IS IT ACTUALLY
COSTS JUST TO PERFORM THE BASIC
FUNCTION OF A BACKGROUND CHECK
IN THE TRANSFER REGISTRY THE
ORIGINAL INTENT.
OF THE DRUG PROGRAM NOT CHASING
DOWN APPS PROGRAMS -- UPDATING
COMPUTER SYSTEMS.
FOR FOR WHO KNOWS WHAT I'M
THERE'S A LOT ON TACKLE MY
COLLEAGUES TALK WITH THAT WERE
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANKS.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SAMPRAS
REPRESENT GUN WAS CALIFORNIA
WANNA MAKE JUST A COUPLE OF
POINTS NUMBER.
ONE THIS BILL IS GOING TO OPEN
UP THE THE THE DROSS.
AS AN ABILITY IF A FUND TO FUND
VIRTUALLY ANYTHING THAT DOJ
WANTS TO DO IN THE REGARDING
FARMS ANYTHING.
I WOULD THINK THAT IN YOUR
OVERSIGHT RESPONSIBILITIES THAT
YOU WOULD BE INTERESTED TO FIND
OUT WHAT IT IS THAT THE DRAWS
FUNDS HAVE GONE TO PAY FOR
WHETHER THEY HAVE BEEN.
TEMPORARY OR PERMANENT LOANS --
WHETHER THEY HAVE BEEN USED.
TO BALANCE THE BUDGET -- BOUGHT
BY GOVERNORS IN THE PAST WHETHER
THEY HAVE BEEN LOANS TO OTHER
PROGRAMS IN ORDER TO FIND
BECAUSE EVERY TIME WE COME UP
HERE.
THE DEPARTMENT SAYS WE MINORING
OBSERVABLE COSTS AND OF YOU KNOW
THE THAT WE KNOW THAT THE THE
DRAWS HAS BEEN THE SOURCE FOR
FUNDING -- THOSE ACTIVITIES JUST
TO PUT THINGS IN PERSPECTIVE.
OVER THE LAST -- SEVEN RAY YEARS --
WITH THE APPROXIMATELY ACTUALLY
MORE THAN SEVEN MILLION GUNS
HAVE BEEN SOLD IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THAT EQUALS MORE THAN A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS THAT HAS GONE
INTO THE THE DRAWS FUN.
WHERE'S THAT MONEY GONE THEY
HAVEN'T HIRED THE YOU KNOW THEY
KEEP THE PUTTING IN P. WISE TO
HIRE MORE PEOPLE TO DO STUFF
THEY'VE UPGRADED THEIR THEIR OF
THEIR SOFTWARE AND AND AND THEN
THEY SAY NOW WE CAN WE CAN COVER
WE CAN DO ALL THESE THINGS.
WE CAN PERFORM MIRACLES.
AND AND STILL -- THIS BEGS A
VERY VERY HUGE QUESTION OF
OVERSIGHT AND OVERSTEPPING AND
THANK GOD IT'S A TWO THIRDS BILL.
THANK MANY OF THE MOST YOUR TIME
TO OKAY I'VE GOT A VERY VERY
VERY BRIEF YOU'VE HAD A VERY
LONG DAY -- KATHY LYNCH
REPRESENT THE NATIONAL SHOOTING
SPORTS FOUNDATION SAFARI CLUB
INTERNATIONAL OUTDOOR
SPORTSMAN'S COALITION IN
CALIFORNIA SPORTSMEN'S LOBBY ALL
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL.
I BELIEVE THIS A CONVERSATION WE
OUGHT TO BE HAVING IN THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE -- AROUND THE ENTIRE
PROGRAM -- WOULD AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE ON THE GUN SHOW ISSUE --
CLEARLY GUN SHOWS AND DEALERS
IT'S AN EXTENSION OF THEIR
BUSINESS ALL THE THE THE LAWS
HAVE TO BE COMPLIED WITH.
THAT YOU CURRENT COME COMPLY
WITH SO THAT'S THAT'S KIND OF A
NON ISSUE.
I WOULD POINT OUT -- TO THAT
THERE ARE TWO LAWSUITS PENDING
ON IN THIS MATTER AND THERE'S
ALSO A PRETTY OPEN ENDED NATURE
WITH -- OTHER FEES IN THE FUN
SUCH AS THE DOLLAR FIREARMS
SAFETY ACT FEE THE FIVE DOLLAR
FIREARM SAFETY AND FOR SOME P.
THAT ARE KIND OF OPEN ENDED.
AND REALLY CAN BE USED FOR ANY
PURPOSE AND IT REALLY FEELS TO
US LIKE.
IF WE'RE GONNA CONVERSATION
CERTAINLY WE CAN APPRECIATE DOJ
HAS CHALLENGES WE ALSO SET HERE
YEAR AFTER YEAR AFTER YEAR AND
IN THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
WHERE THEY CONSTANTLY SAY.
THERE ARE NO COST TO IMPLEMENT
THIS PROGRAM YOU HAVE A MAJOR
DATABASE CHIP SHIFT GOING UP THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WITH THE
AMMUNITION REGISTRATION LONG GUN
REGISTRATION WE KNOW FROM.
CANADA AND OTHER PLACES THAT
IMPOSE THIS THAT THEY'VE HAD
MAJOR DATABASE PROBLEMS AND MANY
LAWSUITS IT FEELS APPROPRIATE
AND TIMELY FOR ALL THE PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA.
IF WE'RE GOING TO HAVE FIREARMS
LAWS THAT ARE GOING TO WORK THEN
WE NEED TO REALLY UNDERSTAND THE
SYSTEM SO WE WOULD REALLY
ENCOURAGE THIS WHOLE
CONVERSATION A MOVE TO THE
BUDGET.
AND WE COMMIT TO ENGAGE IN THAT
PROCESS THANK YOU THANK YOU --
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
DEMOCRATS EUROPEAN CRP ACE AND
ARE A MEMBER AND STRONG
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN IN
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
YOU MAKE CLOTHES MISTER BONTA.
I THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT I THINK THIS IT
CREATES IMPORTANT PARITY BESIDE
BETWEEN FIREARMS DEALERS AND
AMMUNITION VENDORS AND ALSO
PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR
TRUST ACCOUNT TO ACTUALLY FIND.
THE PROGRAMMATIC REQUIREMENTS
THAT WE VAST OF IT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
THANK YOU AND I AND I GUESS IT
DOES FEEL LIKE CALIFORNIA
FIREARMS TAX DAY OF TO MY FRIEND
TO DINNER RATED CALIFORNIA RIFLE
PISTOL SOCIALLY GUN OWNERS OF
AMERICA.
ANY OUTDOOR SPORTSMAN.
I SIT ON BUDGET.
AND I AM REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT
DRUGS AND APPS IN THE END.
OF I TAKE IT ON HIS
RESPONSIBILITIES SINCE I'M ON
SUB FIVE BUDGET.
IT IS A REAL CONCERN.
I HAVE TO AGREE WITH YOU IS A
VERY REAL CONCERN ABOUT HOW THE
MONEY IS PAID.%
AHEAD OF MONIES USED AND
DISSEMINATED BUT I DON'T WANT TO
STOP IT FROM COMING IN.
YOU HAVE A VERY VALID POINT.
ABOUT WE NEED TO FOCUS LIKE A
LASER TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
MONIES ARE SPENT APPROPRIATELY
THAT MAY NOT BE HERE MAYBE
THEY'LL AUDIT GROUP -- YOU MAY
HAVE GIVEN ME AN IDEA FOR NOT IT
SO BE CAREFUL WHAT YOU WISH --
FOR AND CELTIC CHOSE RECOMMEND
HI BUT I'M ALSO KEEP AN EYE ON
BOTH STROH'S.
AND APPS.
ON SIXTEEN SIXTY NINE THAT
MEASURE I'M SORRY THAT MOTION IS
TO PATCH APPROPRIATIONS JONES
SAWYER.
CANCER AYE LACKEY LACKEY NO
BARRICADE HAND DEEP.
BILL DEEP NO KAMLAGER-DOVE.
QUIRK SANTIAGO.
WICKS HI WICKS I THAT.
MEASURES ARE CALLED ME THREE
MORE [inaudible]
AND SO.
I NEED -- TO THANK YOU MR CHAD
THANK YOU CALLING LOCAL STAFF
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS OBERNOLTE
LACKEY M. POWER QUE HAN.
ON THE COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC
SAFETY IS IN RECESS WE WERE
CONVENE RECONVENE AT SIX PM IN
THIS SAME ROOM ONE TWENTY SIX WE
HAVE TO LEAVE.
BECAUSE BUT IT VETERANS AFFAIRS
IS COMING IN RIGHT NOW AND THEY
HAVE THE ROOM RIGHT NOW SO AGAIN.
WE STAND IN RECESS SO I
APOLOGIZE